I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi there! Are you ready to get the girl? Let's go get her! Alright, it's season 8, episode 18, written by Charlie Grandy and directed by Rain Wilson.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是办公室佳人。你好！嗨！你准备好去追那个女孩了吗？我们去把她追回来！好吧，这是第八季第十八集，由查理·格兰迪编剧，雷恩·威尔逊执导。
Here's your summary. Andy drives to Tallahassee to declare his love for Aaron and bring her home. Meanwhile, Nelly shows up in Scranton and helps herself to the manager's position and starts offering everyone a raise. Yeah, also Robert California's there and he just lets it happen. We'll get to that.
以下是剧情概要。安迪开车去塔拉哈西向艾琳表白并带她回家。与此同时，内莉出现在斯克兰顿，擅自占了经理的职位，并开始给每个人加薪。是的，罗伯特·加利福尼亚也在那儿，他只是顺其自然。我们一会儿会讲到这个。
Yeah, before we dive into this episode, you know what, I just need to make a quick phone call. What? I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry, It will be so fast I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Okay. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry dialing Why are you Oh crap sorry. I went to voicemail. Oh, sorry Andy wasn't there. Andy wasn't there. That was a bit It was a bit. You just was a bit. It was a bit.
在深入探讨这一集之前，你知道吗，我只是需要打个简短的电话。什么？我很抱歉。我很抱歉，这真的很快，对不起。对不起。对不起。好吧。好吧。抱歉。抱歉。抱歉，正在拨号。为什么你……哦，糟糕，抱歉。我按到语音信箱了。哦，抱歉，安迪不在。安迪不在。这只是个……这只是个小插曲。你刚刚只是……这只是个小插曲。
You just did a bit. I did a bit. Did you really think I was making a phone call? Of course. Why wouldn't I? You said you had to make a phone call. I thought it would be funny. I mean, Andy's not gonna answer his phone a lot.
你刚才只是在演一出戏。我刚才在演戏。你真的以为我在打电话吗？当然。我怎么会不这么认为？你说你得打个电话。我觉得这挺搞笑的。我是说，安迪不可能一直接电话。
I was like, I'll make a phone call. Yeah. Andy, he's in Tallahassee. Also, that voicemail is so good. It's so good I want to hear the whole thing. I think that if you meet at Helms, you should not ask for a picture. Don't ask for a picture.
我当时想：我要打个电话。是的。安迪，他在塔拉哈西。还有，那个语音信箱太棒了。太棒了，我都想听完整版了。我觉得如果你遇到埃德·赫尔姆斯，你不应该要求合影。不要要求合影。
Oh, Jenna, what are you doing to him? You're about to say ask him to sing his answering machine. Yeah, he should do an audio memo that you can turn into your voicemail. Listen, I would love to do audio memos when I meet people because I don't always feel picture-ready. I don't always want to just, for all time, document the way I do my hair that way or whatever.
哦，珍娜，你对他做了什么？你刚才正要说让他唱他的电话答录机里的留言。是的，他应该录一个语音备忘录，然后你可以把它设成你的语音信箱。听着，我挺想在遇到别人时录语音备忘录的，因为我并不总是随时准备好拍照。我并不总是想把那种状态下的发型或其他什么东西永远记录下来。
So I think I would like it. I'd be like, yeah, sure, I'll do a quick Dunder Miffle and this is Pam. Leave a message. That's a great one. Right? Yeah. Hit me up for audio memos, please.
所以我想我可能会喜欢这样。我会说：“行啊，来个简短的邓德米福尔版吧，我是帕姆。请留言。”这主意太棒了。对吧？是的。请找我录语音备忘录吧，拜托了。
Yeah, I'll just lean into your phone and say, save bandit! Yeah, yeah. This is gonna change our lives. Oh my gosh. I'm gonna, you can really, and Ed, sorry Ed. Sorry. Let's get on to fast fact number one.
对，我会直接凑到你电话旁说：“救救班迪特！”对，对。这会改变我们的生活。哦，天哪。我要……埃德，对不起，埃德。抱歉。我们进入第一个趣味冷知识吧。
This episode aired on March 15th, 2012, and it was not a beloved episode. Sorry to say, in my deep diving of this episode, I just came across a lot of critique. Did you happen to read what Miles wrote about it? You know what, Miles was not even the harshest critic. You're kidding. Miles gave it a C+. Miles McNut, C was not even the harshest critic. You're kidding. Miles gave it a C+.
这一集于2012年3月15日播出，它可不是一集备受喜爱的剧集。很遗憾地告诉大家，在我深入研究这一集的过程中，我看到了大量的差评。你碰巧读过迈尔斯对它的评价吗？你知道吗，迈尔斯甚至还不是最苛刻的评论家。你在开玩笑吧。迈尔斯给它打了C+。迈尔斯·麦克纳特，C甚至还不是最苛刻的评论家。你在开玩笑吧。迈尔斯给它打了C+。
Miles McNut, C+. Who was the harshest critic? There was a critic named Matt Dordy who wrote for the filtered lens and he gave it two out of 10 stars and said that this episode was quote the worst and that it quote lacked any form of logic or emotion. Oh my God. It's like skating.'s like, skating.
迈尔斯·麦克纳特，C+。谁是最苛刻的评论家？有个叫马特·多迪的评论家，他为“过滤镜头”网站撰稿，他给它打了十分之二星，并称这一集“简直烂透了”，而且“完全没有任何逻辑或情感可言”。哦，天哪。这简直就像是滑冰……这就像是个滑冰评论。
Skating review. That is really bad. I know. I'm sorry. That's what I'm saying. I didn't know how to not mention it. No, I know. Because it was all my research led me to these just like,
滑冰评论。这真的很糟糕。我知道。我很抱歉。这就是我想说的。我不知道该怎么避开不提它。不，我懂。因为我所有的研究都让我看到了这些……
really, really harsh reviews. Oh my gosh. OK. It was also ranked 23 out of 24 in the office telling fan pole. It's gonna get worse before it gets better. Matt Dirty also said was anyone else rooting for Aaron to just stay in Florida? I certainly was. And our review from Clack said this episode was quote, miserably insufferable. And quote. Oh my God.
真的非常非常严厉的评价。哦，天哪。好吧。它在《办公室》粉丝投票中还在24集里排名第23位。情况在好转之前还会变得更糟。马特·多迪还说：“还有谁希望艾琳干脆留在佛罗里达的？”我绝对是。我们来自克拉克网站的评论说这一集是“惨绝人寰的折磨”。哦，天哪。
I'm sorry, that's hurting me so hard. Yeah. Oh my gosh. A lot of critics, however, praised Catherine Tate. They were very excited to see what she was going to bring to the show, moving forward. People also praised the balloon cold open. And you know, all that said this episode was still the highest rated show on NBC, the night at aired. So we have that. We have that. That's fast back.
抱歉，这对我打击太大了。是的。哦，天哪。不过，许多评论家赞扬了凯瑟琳·泰特。他们对她接下来在剧中的表现感到非常兴奋。人们还称赞了气球开场。不管怎么说，这一集依然是播出当晚NBC收视率最高的节目。所以我们还有这个。我们还有这个。这是趣味冷知识。
Number one. Okay. Just a lot of bad news. That's fact number one really tickled me. Okay, moving on. Fast fact number two is an office lady's update. We want everyone out there to know we had an amazing show in Toronto at the Just For Last Festival. We kicked off the festival. Yes, we were opening night. Oh my gosh, what a turnout.
第一条。好吧。只是有很多坏消息。第一条趣味冷知识真的让我觉得很有趣。好吧，继续。第二条趣味冷知识是“办公室佳人”的最新动态。我们想让外面的每个人都知道，我们在多伦多的“纯属搞笑”节上有一场精彩的演出。我们为艺术节拉开了序幕。是的，我们是开幕之夜。哦，天哪，观众真多。
You guys, it is so fun to go on the road and see everybody and meet everyone. We did like an impromptu little meet and greet kind of after the show and we got to meet a lot of people. We did. We didn't have a formal meet and greet for the show, but there was a show right after us.
大家伙儿，去各地巡演并见到所有人、认识每个人真是太有趣了。我们在演出结束后举办了一场即兴的小型见面会，我们见到了很多人。确实如此。我们为这场演出没有安排正式的见面会，但紧接着我们之后还有一场演出。
So they were kicking us out. But we were like, we're gonna take 15, 20 minutes. We went to the front of the stage. We signed as many things as we could. We took as many selfies as we could. But it was, I mean, we're always kind of doing our, our, in a vacuum, we, you know, we do it, and then it goes on TV, or we talk in our microphones,
所以他们一直在赶我们走。但我们当时想，我们要花15、20分钟。我们走到舞台前。我们尽可能多地给东西签名。我们尽可能多地拍自拍照。但这太……我是说，我们总是有点像在……在真空环境中，你知道的，我们完成录制，然后它上了电视，或者我们对着话筒说话，
and then, in our closets, or in a little room, and we're like, oh, I guess, maybe someone listened. So this was the joy of live performance. And I love our live show. Me too. And something really exciting happened, which is why I was bringing it up. While we were there in Toronto, we solved the smell rusty. Did you combine smell and mystery? I did. Did you like it? I did, a smelly street. A smelly street, a smelly street. One of those. Okay.
然后，在我们的衣帽间里，或者在一个小房间里，我们就会想：哦，我想，也许有人听了吧。所以这就是现场演出的乐趣所在。我爱我们的现场演出。我也是。而且发生了一件非常令人兴奋的事，这也是我提起这个的原因。当我们在多伦多的时候，我们破解了“气味秘密”。你把“气味”和“秘密”结合起来了吗？我结合了。你喜欢吗？我喜欢，一条臭气熏天的街道。一条臭气熏天的街道，一条臭气熏天的街道。其中之一。好吧。
Of the Canadian $100 bill. Yes. Yes. During our breakdown of last day in Florida, we got a letter from Amy and Nova Scotia who told us that there was this crazy thing that happened where people in Canada thought that the new $100 bill smelled like maple syrup.
关于加拿大100加元钞票的。是的。是的。在我们剖析“在佛罗里达的最后一天”时，我们收到了来自新斯科舍省的艾米的一封信，她告诉我们发生了一件疯狂的事：加拿大人认为新版100加元钞票闻起来像枫糖浆。
Well, we brought this up during our live show. Mm-hmm. And a woman in the front row had a $100 Canadian bill. Yes, she just popped right up. She was like, I have one. Do you want to smell it? We're like, yes. So we smelled it. Here are the results.
好吧，我们在现场演出时提起了这件事。嗯哼。前排的一位女士有一张100加元的加拿大钞票。是的，她一下子就跳出来了。她当时说：“我有一张。你想闻闻吗？”我们说：“好啊。”于是我们闻了闻。以下是结果。
Jenna, what did you think? Did it smell like maple syrup? No. Angela? I thought it did. think? Did it smell like maple syrup? No, Angela. I thought it did. I could smell it. So I don't know what that is, but we have now smelled a Canadian $100 bill. Thank you to the woman in the front row for letting us smell your money.
珍娜，你觉得怎么样？它闻起来像枫糖浆吗？不。安吉拉？我觉得像。你觉得呢？它闻起来像枫糖浆吗？不，安吉拉。我觉得像。我能闻出来。所以，我不知道那是什么，但我们现在确实闻过一张100加元的加拿大钞票了。谢谢前排的那位女士让我们闻了闻你的钱。
Yes, and also, I have had a few people say to me, do you say syrup or syrup? I say syrup. I say syrup. I wanna know what Sam and Cassie say. Oh. I say syrup. And I say syrup.
是的，还有，也有好几个人对我说：你到底是说“syrup”（糖浆，发音为sir-up）还是“syrup”（发音为seer-up）？我说“syrup”。我说“syrup”。我想知道萨姆和凯西是怎么说的。哦。我说“syrup”。我说“syrup”。
You guys were divided. It's like a 50-50. I went on to Google Translate and I typed in the word syrup. And here's what Google Translate has to say. Ready? Mm-hmm. Sarah. Sarah.
你们俩意见不一。简直是五五开。我打开了谷歌翻译，输入了“syrup”这个词。谷歌翻译是这么说的。准备好了吗？嗯哼。萨拉。萨拉。
Sarah. It sounds like the combination of syrup and syrup. It sounds like syrup to me. I hear syrup. Mm-hmm. This is our... What are you doing today? What are you doing?
萨拉。听起来像是“syrup”和“syrup”的结合体。在我听来就是“syrup”。我听到的是“syrup”。嗯哼。这就是我们的……你今天在干什么？你在干什么？
This is our Laurel Yawney moment. Do you say syrup or syrup? Hmm. What are you doing today? What are you doing? This is our Laurel Yawney moment. Do you say syrup or syrup? What are you here? I want you to know. I just googled syrup. And did you know that there is an American pronunciation? And a British pronunciation?
这就是我们的“劳瑞尔·亚尼”时刻。你到底是说“syrup”还是“syrup”？嗯。你今天在干什么？你在干什么？这就是我们的“劳瑞尔·亚尼”时刻。你到底是说“syrup”还是“syrup”？你在这儿听到什么了？我想让你们知道。我刚才谷歌了一下“syrup”。你知道吗，它有一种美式发音？还有英式发音？
Are you British, Jenna? Maybe I am. You tell me. Syrup. Syrup. I am. You tell me. Serip. Serip. Serip. You're British. I'm British.
你是英国人吗，珍娜？也许我是。你告诉我。Syrup。Syrup。我是。你告诉我。Serip。Serip。Serip。你是英国人。我是英国人。
Cassie, we're British. Sam, we're American. Moving on now to fast-fac number three, Angela, my favorite thing is when I take fast-fac number three. You have a fast-fac number three for us. What do you got? You know, I was just curious about where all the office has been remade. Then I looked it up.
凯西，我们是英国人。萨姆，我们是美国人。现在进入第三条趣味冷知识，安吉拉，我最喜欢的就是由我来播报第三条趣味冷知识。你为我们准备了第三条趣味冷知识。你有什么料？你知道的，我只是好奇《办公室》都在哪些地方被翻拍过。于是我查了一下。
Well, I know they just are about to launch one in Australia with a female boss. Yes. OK, so the new Australian version has gotten a lot of buzz online. It's in production right now. OK. And obviously, we all know the OG version, which was created in the United Kingdom by Ricky
嗯，我知道他们刚准备在澳大利亚推出一个版本，老板是个女性。是的。好吧，新的澳大利亚版本在网上引起了很多轰动。现在正在制作中。好吧。很显然，我们都知道由里奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·麦钱特在英国创作的原版，但他们的创意已经传到了其他所有国家。
Jervais and Stephen Merchant, but their idea has spread to all these other countries. There have been office remakes in Brazil, Canada, Chile, the Czech Republic, Finland, France, Germany, Greece, India, Israel, Poland, Saudi Arabia, Sweden, and of course our version in the United States. And here's the thing I found really interesting. A lot of these remakes were starting right when our show started. At the same time. At the same time.
巴西、加拿大、智利、捷克共和国、芬兰、法国、德国、希腊、印度、以色列、波兰、沙特阿拉伯、瑞典，当然还有我们在美国的版本，都对《办公室》进行了翻拍。而且我发现了一件非常有意思的事。许多这样的翻拍版正是在我们的剧刚开播时就开始了。同一时间。同一时间。
Yeah. And they didn't run as long as ours did, but you can see all of their TV posters for their remakes. They're on IMDB. I can put them in stories. Isn't it true? I remember hearing this, that the France, Jim and Pam were like gorgeous, like runway models.
是的。而且它们的播出时间没有我们的长，但你可以在IMDB上看到它们所有翻拍版的电视海报。我可以把它们发到快拍里。难道不是吗？我记得好像听过这样的说法，法国版的吉姆和帕姆简直美得像T台模特。
Yes. They were super, super beautiful. Yes. In fact, I'll tell you how they're described. Okay. The Jim Pam characters are stunning and new bile up in cummers. And then the article said, this is France after all. You know, we get asked all the time, there are always these rumors of another American version, like a
是的。他们超级超级漂亮。是的。事实上，我来告诉你是怎么形容他们的。好吧。吉姆和帕姆的角色是惊艳动人的新人。然后文章说，这毕竟是法国嘛。你知道的，我们总是被问到各种问题，总是有关于另一个美国版本的谣言，比如重启版、翻拍版或衍生剧。
reboot or remake or a spin off. Yeah, no one has ever in all of these years ever one time contacted me about being on another version of the office. Or any cast member, whenever I talk to the cast members, they're like, never heard anything, not a word. And we get like tagged in all these articles all the time, and then we'll have like a text thread, like, guys any truth to this? Nope, no one's read up to me, never heard of it.
是的，在所有这些年里，从来没有人哪怕一次联系过我，让我去拍另一个版本的《办公室》。或者任何演员，每当我跟演员们交流时，他们都说：从没听说过，一个字都没听过。我们经常在所有这些文章里被@，然后我们就会在一个群聊里说：“伙计们，这有什么依据吗？没有，没人联系过我，从没听说过。”
Every time one of these news articles comes out, my phone blows up from people who've read this article. Is it happening? Did you hear? Are you on it? What's going on? And I can only ever say the same thing. No one has ever contacted me. I don't know anything about it. I don't know what it is. It's like every couple of years, it just, the rumor catches fire again. Yeah. But listen, we don't work at NBC Universal. We're just two gals talking about our lives. But you know, I would say this. If there was ever any truth to it,
每当这类新闻文章发表时，我的电话就会被读过这篇文章的人打爆。是真的吗？你听说了吗？你有参演吗？怎么回事？而我永远只能回答同一句话。从来没有人联系过我。我对此一无所知。我不知道这是什么。就好像每隔几年，这个谣言就会再次死灰复燃。是的。但听着，我们不在NBC环球工作。我们只是两个畅谈生活的姑娘。不过你知道的，我会这么说。如果这有哪怕一点点真实性，
Greg would reach out to us. He definitely would. I did see that Greg briefly addressed this in an interview with Collider. He said, well, I think that is very speculative. The fact that it kind of blew up based on one line in a puck piece was kind of cool. I guess in the sense that the fans still care a lot. And then he went on to say the thing I would say is when there's something to announce,
格雷格肯定会联系我们的。他绝对会的。我确实看到格雷格在接受《Collider》采访时简短地回应了这一点。他说：“嗯，我认为这非常具有推测性。它仅仅基于帕克网站上的一行字就大肆发酵，这其实挺酷的。我想，从粉丝们依然非常在乎的角度来看是这样的。”接着他又说：“我要说的是，当有什么需要宣布的时候，
I will definitely announce it. It's true. So there you go. Maybe there will be one one day. I don't think I'll be on it. I mean, I'm gonna be 50 next year. Do we need a 50-year-old Pam sitting at a desk and under a meal? I don't think we do. We might need a 50-year-old Pam cameo. I'll pop in.
我一定会宣布的。”确实如此。所以就是这样。也许有一天真的会有吧。我觉得我不会参演。我是说，我明年就50岁了。我们还需要一个50岁的帕姆坐在邓德米福尔的办公桌前吗？我觉得不需要。我们或许需要一个50岁帕姆的客串。我会去露个面。
Yeah. I'm up for a pop-in. Yeah. Old, crusty, angel, Martin will pop in too. I really like the idea if they ever remade the office that Creed still works there. A hundred percent. And maybe Meredith. Or if Creed doesn't work there,
是的。我随时准备露面。是的。老态龙钟、脾气古怪的安吉拉·马丁也会去露面。我真的挺喜欢这个想法的：如果他们重拍《办公室》的话，克里德还在那儿工作。百分之百。也许还有梅雷迪思。或者如果克里德不在那儿工作，
he just lives in the warehouse, like in the back corner. Yes. Yes, he comes down from the ceiling at night. Yeah, exactly. Well, that's all I got for FastFacts. Thank you for your FastFact, Angela. I really enjoyed that. Oh, you're welcome.
他就住在仓库里，比如后面的角落里。是的。是的，他晚上会从天花板上爬下来。是的，完全没错。好吧，这就是我所有的趣味冷知识了。谢谢你的趣味冷知识，安吉拉。我很喜欢。哦，不客气。
I mean, I guess there's about 80 countries that have options to this. So who knows? I might miss one by the time that article was published and I read it, there might be more. Well, should we take a break? And then when we come back, we can talk about the balloon. Yes. We are back. And before we get started, I just want to say if you like your coffee to stay real hot on the go, you really need to get our office ladies BFF coffee tumbler. My coffee
我是说，我想大约有80个国家拥有这个版权。所以谁知道呢？等那篇文章发表我读到它的时候，也许我漏掉了一些，可能还会有更多。好吧，我们该休息一下吗？等我们回来，我们可以聊聊气球的事。好的。我们回来了。在我们开始之前，我只想说，如果你喜欢你的咖啡在出门时能保持真正的热度，你真的需要买一个我们的“办公室佳人”BFF咖啡随行杯。我的咖啡
is still so hot, so, so hot. And it would stay super, super cold too. If you put ice in it. It's a colder. You can do cold and hot with it. Who would get I even know this? It's my own merch. I didn't know I could put cold stuff in it. Oh my gosh, it will stay so cold. I've put iced tea in there with ice and it's's been cold for an entire day. The next day, I woke up, I forgot I hadn't poured it out. There was still ice in it. Wow. Yeah, it's really good.
依然超级热，超级超级热。而且如果你放了冰块，它也能保持超级超级冷。如果你在里面加冰。它是保温的。你既可以用它装冷的，也可以装热的。谁会连这都知道？这可是我自己的周边商品。我以前都不知道我还能用它装冰镇的东西。哦天哪，它能保持好久的冰凉。我把冰茶和冰块一起放进去，整整一天它都保持着冰凉。第二天醒来，我忘了把它倒掉。里面居然还有冰块。哇。是的，真的很棒。
And it has a handle, guys. I wanted something with a handle because I like to drink my tea. I don't always want some huge thing, you know, like a craft, a coffee that you travel out the door with. I would love. I would love someone to just travel with a craft.
而且它带有一个手柄，伙计们。我想要一个带手柄的，因为我喜欢喝茶。我不总是想要那种巨大的东西，你知道的，比如出门时随身携带的那种大壶咖啡。我真希望有人能带着一大壶到处走。
You know what I mean? Somebody I do. I do. Travel things are so big. And I liked that this one was like kind of like a cup of tea. Well, my coffee is still so hot. It's I poured it in there like an hour ago. But let's get started. This episode begins with Pam getting a very important urgent phone call at her desk. Yeah, I guess there's a balloon that has been cut in the rafters of the warehouse for years. It's finally coming down. Yeah, the whole office is going to go down and watch this balloon slowly fall. Pam says, you know, it doesn't sound cool, but you just have to see it.
你知道我的意思吗？有人……我确实希望。我确实希望。出门带的东西太大了。我喜欢这款，它有点像一杯茶。好吧，我的咖啡依然好热。我大概一个小时前才倒进去的。但我们开始吧。这一集开始于帕姆在她的办公桌前接听了一个非常重要且紧急的电话。是的，我猜仓库的屋顶横梁上卡了一个气球好多年了。它终于要掉下来了。是的，整个办公室的人都要下去观看这个气球缓缓落下。帕姆说，你知道的，听起来可能不够酷，但你必须亲眼看看。
Then we go and we see it. And then she says, you know what, it doesn't really look cool either, but it is a big deal. So everyone goes down to the warehouse. It's very exciting. They formed a circle and they're watching this balloon just very, very slowly fall to the ground. Pam says, did a good job, buddy. Now it's time to come home. Did anyone else catch the huge Angela Martin eye roll at Pam? It's back, guys.
然后我们走过去看到了它。接着她说，你知道吗，其实看起来也不是很酷，但这是一件大事。于是大家全都去了仓库。这非常令人兴奋。他们围成一圈，看着这个气球非常非常缓慢地落向地面。帕姆说：“干得好，伙计。现在是时候回家了。”有没有人注意到安吉拉·马丁对帕姆翻了个巨大的白眼？它又回来了，伙计们。
The eye roll is back. I saw it. And now everyone begins to reminisce about their first memories of when they saw the balloon. Oscar says, wow, you know, I was still with Gil. Kevin says, I had hair like Rapunzel. And Dwight's work craft clan was still on speaking terms. Meredith's kid hadn't gotten a face tattoo yet.
翻白眼又回来了。我看到了。接着大家都开始回忆起他们第一次看到这个气球时的记忆。奥斯卡说：“哇，你知道吗，那时候我和吉尔还在一起呢。”凯文说：“我当时留着长发，就像长发公主一样。”德怀特的工会克兰还在和他们保持友好交往。梅雷迪思的孩子还没纹脸部刺青呢。
Darryl was thinking of going back to school and Jim was just a paper salesman. Yeah, little sarcasm there from Jim. Little sarcasm. Everyone's kind of bummed now. Yeah, thanks Pam, they say. But then Darryl is gonna pop the balloon using the forklift and everyone cheers.
达里尔当时正考虑重返校园，而吉姆还只是个纸品推销员。是的，吉姆发出了轻微的讽刺。一点点讽刺。现在大家都觉得有点扫兴了。是的，谢谢你啊帕姆，他们说。但接着达里尔要用叉车把气球戳破，大家齐声欢呼。
Everyone cheers, kill the balloon. We got a lot of fan mail about this cold open. Chris H from Lafayette, Indiana, Kelsey S from Toronto and many others. Really want to know, how did we get the balloon to fall? Was there really a balloon? Was it CGI? How did this work? How did we manage to get the timing just right? Well, guess who told me all the deets?
大家欢呼雀跃，戳破气球。我们收到了很多关于这个开场白集的粉丝来信。来自印第安纳州拉斐特的克里斯·H、来自多伦多的凯尔西·S以及许多其他人。非常想知道：我们是怎么让气球落下来的？真的有气球吗？是CGI特效吗？这是怎么运作的？我们是怎么把时间掐得刚刚好的？好吧，猜猜是谁告诉我所有细节的？
Steve Burgess. Steve Burgess, because I couldn't remember. I couldn't remember. Were we looking at a real balloon or not? I thought we were. I thought we were, but then I was like, how did we make that happen? Was it like on a fishing hook or something,
史蒂夫·伯吉斯。史蒂夫·伯吉斯，因为我都记不清了。我记不清了。我们当时看的是真气球还是假的？我以为是真的。我以为是的，但后来我想：我们是怎么做到这一点的？它是挂在鱼钩上还是别的什么上面，
and there was like a ladder, and like someone would like a, I feel like there was like a, a rod and reel situation happening. You are correct. There really was a balloon, it was not CGI, it was inflated with air, not helium, and we had a special effects person on a ladder, off camera, and he had a fishing pole
然后就像有个梯子，有人拿着一个……我感觉当时好像有鱼竿和绕线轮在那儿运作。你猜对了。确实有个气球，不是CGI特效，里面充的是空气而不是氦气，我们有一个特效人员站在梯子上，在镜头拍不到的地方，他手里拿着一根鱼竿，
with some of that mono filament, which is fishing line attached to the balloon. And he just lowered the balloon at the speed we needed. Wait, mono filament. Mono filament. Is another word for fishing line? The way Steve Berger's wrote his email it is because he wrote mono filament and then he put fishing line in parentheses.
鱼竿上有一些单丝线，也就是连着气球的钓鱼线。他只是按照我们需要速度把气球放下来。等等，单丝线。单丝线。是钓鱼线的另一个词吗？史蒂夫·伯吉斯写邮件时的用法就是这样的，因为他写了“单丝线”，然后在括号里写了“钓鱼线”。
I never knew that. So like if we went down to a dock, could I be like, hey, can I have some mono filament? Yes. Okay. I'm going to encourage you to do that. I'm going to save that. Oh man. I really want to go fishing, but I need some extra mono filament. Yeah. I would fish with you, but I'm out of mono filament. Yeah, I'm sorry. I can't please. Please do this. You know who could probably tell us if this is true as the folks at Bass Masters? I love Bass Masters.
我以前从来不知道这一点。所以，如果我去码头，我可以说：“嘿，能给我点单丝线吗？”可以。好吧。我鼓励你这么做。我要把它记下来。天哪。我真的很想去钓鱼，但我需要一些额外的单丝线。对。我会陪你钓鱼，但我没有单丝线了。是的，对不起。我不能……求求你，请这么做。你知道谁能告诉我们这是否属实吗？是“鲈鱼大师”的人吗？我爱“鲈鱼大师”。
We love them. I wore my hoodie the other day to play tennis. I still have my leather journal from Bass Masters. It's a great one. Steve Burgess said that it also made it really easy to do multiple takes using the monofilament technique. And he reminded me that when Craig popped the balloon, we had to tape it to the ground
我们爱他们。我前几天打网球时还穿着他们的连帽衫。我到现在还保留着从“鲈鱼大师”买的皮革日记本。那是个好本子。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，使用单丝线技术也使得拍摄多个镜头变得非常容易。而且他提醒我，当克雷格戳破气球时，我们不得不把它固定在地面上，
so that it wouldn't slide out from under the forklift. And Craig had to be certified to drive the forklift and use it. That's kind of a cool thing to have, like on your resume, like, oh yeah, I can drive a forklift. He could put that in his special skills. He could. Well listen before we break down the rest of the episode I have a little something from
这样它就不会从叉车底下溜走了。而且克雷格必须获得驾驶和使用叉车的资格证。把这种经历写进简历里其实挺酷的，比如：“哦，是的，我会开叉车。”他可以把它写进他的特殊技能里。他确实可以。好吧，听着，在我们剖析本集的其余部分之前，我有一点来自
my digital clutter I wanted to share with you. What's that? The week we filmed this episode I emailed you and I want to read you what I sent. All right. This would have been January. Mm-hmm. It was. Yeah.
我的数字杂乱文档里的东西想跟你们分享。什么东西？我们拍摄这一集的那个星期我给你发过邮件，我想读给你听听我当时发了什么。好的。这应该是在一月份。嗯哼。是的。
January 12th. Okay. Okay. The subject was titled, I Want to Buy This, LOL. Okay. When you opened the email, I wrote, go to beachbody.com and look up Brazilian butt lift, thinking of trying this.
1月12日。好的。好的。主题是“我想买这个，哈哈”。好的。当你打开邮件时，我写道：“去beachbody.com查看‘巴西提臀术’，考虑试试这个。”
Lady, yeah, what is it? You wrote back. Too funny, three exclamation points. Somebody put the heck were we talking about? So I went to the link that was in my email. It's an old link, but this is what it said. Leandro Cavaljo's Brazilian Budlift. This super focused hardcore workout will reshape your booty, lifting, firming, and rounding it with strategic,
天哪，是的，那是什么？你回信了。太搞笑了，三个感叹号。某人……我们到底在说什么啊？所以我点开了我邮件里的链接。那是个旧链接，但上面是这么写的：莱安德罗·卡瓦尔霍的巴西提臀术。这个超级专注的硬核锻炼将重塑你的臀部，通过战略性的、
targeted sculpting routines. It's so much fun, you'll forget, you're working your butt off. And then there is a separate article that said, what type of workout is best for my butt type? Oh, yeah. Did you figure out what your exercise, wait, can I still buy this product?
有针对性的雕塑训练来提升、紧致和圆润你的臀部。这太有趣了，你会忘记你正在拼命锻炼你的屁股。然后还有一篇单独的文章写道：“哪种锻炼最适合我的臀部类型？”哦，是的。你弄清楚你的锻炼方式了吗，等等，我还能买到这个产品吗？
By the way, did you buy it? Is it here? It's a series of workouts. It's like videos and workouts, right? So I'm buying workout videos. You're buying workout videos. I thought it was a product. No, I never did it.
顺便问一句，你买了吗？它在这儿吗？它是一系列锻炼课程。就像是视频和锻炼，对吧？所以你在买锻炼视频。你在买锻炼视频。我以为它是一个产品。不，我从来没买过。
Okay. I never subscribed. I never did the workout. But I think it still lives. Oh, it. Okay. I never subscribed. I never did the workout. But I think it still lives. Oh, yes. Okay. But anyway, this is what you and I were emailing about when we made this episode.
好吧。我从来没订购过。我从来没做过那个锻炼。但我觉得它现在可能还在。哦，它。好吧。我从来没订购过。我从来没做过那个锻炼。但我觉得它现在可能还在。哦，是的。好吧。不管怎样，这就是你和我拍这一集时发邮件讨论的内容。
I wanted to reshape my booty. I wish I had known this before I rewatched it. I would have looked for signs of this in your performance. You know. The secret one that I had. All right, well let's get into this episode. We have the opening credits which was interesting that they did not change for Nelly. Oh, we got a fan mail flurry about that Angela. Oh yeah, really? We did. So many people wrote in to say, how come we didn't have Nelly as the final manager image
我想重塑我的屁股。我要是早知道这一点，在重温这一集时就不会错过了。我会在你的表演中寻找这方面的迹象。你知道的。我曾经有过的那个秘密。好吧，让我们进入这一集吧。片头字幕开始了，有趣的是他们没有为内莉更换片头。哦，安吉拉，我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝来信讨论这件事。哦，真的吗？是的。有好多人写信来问：“为什么我们没有把内莉作为最终的经理头像放上去，
since we've done that with everyone else, including Creed? I thought about it, and here's my theory. Okay. If they set up her at the desk at the very top, it ruins the whole storyline and the surprise that she's taking over Andy's job slowly but surely. Well, do you think she'll be there next week? That's what I'm curious about. Me too. I didn't watch's what I'm curious about. Me too.
既然我们对所有其他人，包括克雷格，都这么做了？”我想过了，这是我的理论。好的。如果他们在最开始就把她安排在那张办公桌前，那就破坏了整条故事情节，也破坏了她慢慢接替安迪工作的悬念和惊喜。好吧，你觉得她下周还会在这儿吗？这就是我好奇的地方。我也是。我没看……这就是我好奇的地方。我也是。
I didn't watch ahead. I didn't either. Well, find out next week! Yeah! The episode starts with Jim and Pam arriving to work. They got an extra breakfast sandwich. Does anyone want it? Guess who wants it?
我没有提前看。我也没有。好吧，下周见分晓！耶！剧集以吉姆和帕姆到达公司开始。他们多买了一份早餐三明治。有人想要吗？猜猜谁想要？
Nelly appears out of nowhere and she's back and she's eating their sandwich. And she does not like it. She says it's disgusting. She says, you call this a King James breakfast pie? I looked it up. It's really weird because it's believed to have originated in England. And it's basically a pie.
内莉不知从哪儿冒了出来，她回来了，而且她正在吃他们的三明治。她还挺嫌弃。她说这太难吃。她说：“你们管这叫詹姆斯国王早餐派？”我查了一下。这真的很奇怪，因为它被认为起源于英国。它基本上就是一个派。
And it has layers of bacon, sausage, eggs, cheese. Sometimes hash browns or mushrooms all baked together. Okay. I don't understand how you take it on the go. I saw some pictures where it looked like a pizza pocket, where it was like pie on top and bottom, and then some that just looked like a pie, but I cannot get any origin story
里面有培根、香肠、鸡蛋、奶酪的夹层。有时还会烤上薯饼或蘑菇。好吧。我不明白你怎么能把它当成边走边吃的东西。我看到一些图片，它看起来像披萨口袋，上下都有派皮，还有一些看起来就像个派，但我找不到任何关于
on the King James breakfast pie. Why is it called the King James breakfast pie? Who really invented it? Some people say it was like an American invention based on British breakfast. I don't know. I was very frustrating. It sounds good. It really looked good. I didn't bake one, but you know. I'm so surprised. Well, I'm so surprised you don't have it for all of us to try today. Well, you know, what's happening to you? I don't know. Nelly is also going to dig on the Houdini Museum. Mm-hmm.
詹姆斯国王早餐派的起源故事。为什么它叫詹姆斯国王早餐派？到底是谁发明的？有些人说这是基于英式早餐的一项美国发明。我不知道。这太让人沮丧了。听起来很好吃。看起来确实很好吃。我没有烤一个，不过你知道的。我很惊讶。好吧，我很惊讶你今天居然没有给我们大家准备一个尝尝。好吧，你懂的，你怎么了？我不知道。内莉还要对胡迪尼博物馆冷嘲热讽一番。嗯哼。
And then she announces she's come to work in Scranton. Toby walks right up to her and introduces himself as Tony. We got so much mail about that. Oh my gosh. He's so casually then tried to cover this up. I thought has he introduced himself as Tony before and why would he? Is this his Grant and Strangler clue? Well, we had a fan theory from Natasha M in Wales who said, I think maybe his name was Tony all along. But someone
接着她宣布她来斯克兰顿工作了。托比径直走到她面前，自我介绍说他是托尼。我们收到了好多关于这个的邮件。哦，天哪。他当时表现得那么随性，然后试图掩盖过去。我在想，他以前曾介绍过自己叫托尼吗？他为什么要这么做？难道这是他的“斯克兰顿扼喉狂”线索吗？好吧，我们收到了来自威尔士的娜塔莎·M的粉丝理论，她说：“我觉得也许他的名字本来就叫托尼。但有一天某人
called him Toby one day and he just didn't correct them and now it's spiraled and he will be forever known as Toby instead of his real name of Tony. Natasha, that's hilarious. You totally flipped it. That is so funny. You know, I thought maybe Tony is his alternate identity. Tony's a different guy. We all know Tony. Like Jekyll and Hyde, Tony and Toby.
叫他托比，他当时只是没有纠正他们，现在事情越闹越大，他将永远被称为托比，而不是他的真名托尼。”娜塔莎，这太搞笑了。你完全把这事反转了。这也太好笑了吧。你知道的，我一直在想，也许托尼是他的另一个身份。托尼是另一个人。我们都知道托尼。就像杰基尔和海德一样，托尼和托比。
Yeah. Yeah. We had a fan catch from Amanda A. in North Carolina who said, Toby seems to not know who Nelly is and introduces himself, but didn't Toby already meet Nelly at the end of season seven in search committee when she interviewed for the manager position. Such a good catch. He's sat across the table from her. Yeah. Yeah. And also, doesn't he know she's the president of special projects? Like, as the HR manager, he sent a bunch of his employees
是的。是的。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的阿曼达·A的粉丝抓包，她说：“托比好像不认识内莉是谁，还主动自我介绍，可是托比不是已经在第七季末的‘搜寻委员会’里，当内莉面试经理职位时见过她了吗？”真是个精彩的抓包。他当时就坐在她对面呢。是的。是的。而且，难道他不知道她是特别项目主管吗？作为人事经理，他把手下一大群员工
to another state to work on a project. Wouldn't he know who they're working under? Come on, there'd be forms to fill out. There's definitely forms. There's so many forms. Yeah. What's happening to Toby? I don't know.
派到另一个州去参与一个项目。难道他会不知道他们的顶头上司是谁吗？拜托，总得有表格要填吧。绝对有表格。有超级多的表格。是的。托比到底怎么了？我不知道。
Well, Tony tells Nelly, welcome, find a desk, have a seat, and then we'll wait for Robert to arrive. Nelly notices there's an empty seat in Andy's office. She'll take that seat and that job. Yeah, she says her business philosophy is simple. If the seat is open, the job is open. That's how she came to briefly race a Formula One car. Mm-hmm.
好吧，托尼告诉内莉：“欢迎，找张办公桌坐下吧，然后我们等罗伯特来。”内莉注意到安迪的办公室里有个空位。她要占那个座位，接管那份工作。是的，她说她的商业哲学很简单：如果位子空着，工作就是空着的。她就是靠这个短暂地去赛过一场F1赛车的。嗯哼。
Slowest laps ever recorded. Ever recorded. I love that it's like a record. You are a record holder in a sense. Exactly. Down in Tallahassee, Aaron is walking out to get the newspaper. Alonzo drives by. She tries to make small talk with him.
有史以来记录的最慢圈速。有史以来。我喜欢这就像是个纪录。从某种意义上说，你是个纪录保持者。没错。在塔拉哈西，艾琳正走出去拿报纸。阿隆索开车路过。她试图跟他闲聊。
He just keeps driving. Yes. Well, Alonzo was played by Alexander Sabaha. He did a great job. So drives by she tries to make small talk with him he just keeps driving yes Well, Alonzo was played by Alexander Sabaha. He did a great job. He did fantastic I cracked up when he just kept going and now lady I really have a special award to give out Okay, are you ready because the award for the worst green screen and the run of our show goes to Aaron's Talking Head. Congratulations. Congratulations. This was a fan mail flurry. I talked to Steve Burgess about it. He said, yeah, it was a talking head that they had to add later on a green screen. He said there were two talking heads that were added after we shot this episode and this was one of them. And I don't know why they couldn't just walk over to the outside of Tom Melby's house.
他却径直把车开走了。是的。好吧，阿隆索由亚历山大·萨巴哈饰演。他演得棒极了。所以他开车路过，她试图跟他闲聊，他却径直把车开走了。是的。好吧，阿隆索由亚历山大·萨巴哈饰演。他演得棒极了。他演得太棒了。当他直接开走时，我笑喷了。现在，各位，我真的有一个特别的奖项要颁发。好吧，你们准备好了吗？因为全剧最差绿幕奖要颁给艾琳的单人访谈。恭喜。恭喜。这是粉丝来信里热议的话题。我和史蒂夫·伯吉斯聊过这件事。他说：“是的，那是他们后来在绿幕上补拍的一个单人访谈。”他说有两场单人访谈是在我们拍摄完这一集之后补拍的，这就是其中之一。我不知道他们为什么不直接走到汤姆·梅尔比家外面去拍。
It was right there. Yeah. But I guess instead they filmed it as a plate and then they shot her talking head on a green screen. It was real awful. It was so obvious. It was crazy. I told you that when I was researching
房子就在那儿。是的。但我想他们当时拍的可能是个实景底片，然后在一个绿幕前拍了她的单人访谈。真的太糟糕了。太明显了。太疯狂了。我告诉过你，当我研究
this episode, it was just like a lot of critical articles. This talking head came up a lot for its terrible green screen effect. Well, I get it. In this talking head, we're going to learn that Aaron is a maid for an old lady. Runs her errands, gets to clean all five rooms of the house, not to brag. Back at Dundermiffland, Robert arrives. Runs her errands, gets to clean all five rooms of the house, not to brag. Back at Dundermiffland, Robert arrives. He greets Nelly, asks her how she's adjusting, and he says, I can't wait to find something fun for you to do here. Yeah, Nelly says, you know what, I've already taken care of that. I found something. I'm the manager. He says, we already have a manager, and I love this line. She says, oh really? Because it's 10am, I've been in this office for an hour and no one has come and sat in my lap.
这一集时，看到了好多批判性的文章。这个单人访谈因为其糟糕的绿幕效果而被屡次提及。好吧，我明白了。在这个单人访谈中，我们了解到艾琳是一个老太太的女佣。帮她跑腿，还得打扫家里全部五个房间，这可不是吹牛。回到邓德米福尔，罗伯特来了。帮她跑腿，还得打扫家里全部五个房间，这可不是吹牛。回到邓德米福尔，罗伯特来了。他跟内莉打招呼，问她适应得怎么样，并说：“我已经迫不及待想为你找点有趣的事在这里做了。”是的，内莉说：“你知道吗，我已经把这事搞定了。我找到事做了。我是经理。”他说：“我们已经有一个经理了，我太喜欢这句台词了。”她说：“哦，是吗？因为现在是上午10点，我已经在办公室坐了一个小时了，还没有任何人来坐在我大腿上。”
I don't think you're a manager. By all standards, you don't have a manager. Well now everyone is really wondering where Andy is. You know, he's usually here by now and they start to discuss. There were a few versions of this scene and there's one where Ryan and Oscar really get into it and I want you to hear it. Has anyone talked to Andy? He's not returning any calls. I checked his Facebook status at Pump for Wednesday. Today's Thursday.
我觉得你才不是经理。无论从什么标准来看，你都不是经理。好吧，现在大家都在纳闷安迪去哪儿了。你知道的，他平时这个时候已经到了，他们开始讨论起来。这个场景有好几个版本，其中有一个是瑞安和奥斯卡杠上了，我想让你们听听。有人跟安迪联系过吗？他什么电话都不回。我查了他在水泵厂的脸书状态是星期三。今天是星期四。
I hate to take it to this place but re- Andy has anyone checked the morgue. Oh. Checking the morgue is not a real thing. That's a real thing. You're a policeman? No, I'm a morgue. You're just like, hey, can I look around? Anyone?
我本来不想往这方面想，但……安迪，有人查过太平间吗？哦。查太平间可不是常规操作。这是常规操作。你是警察吗？不，我是太平间。你就是那种去问“嘿，我能四处看看吗？有人吗？”的人。
Yeah, they have names on everything. I didn't know you were a morgue. Then you go to the graveyard. Then you go to the graveyard. Okay, okay, okay. Okay, cemetery. All right. What is that?
对啊，他们每样东西上面都有名字。我可不知道你还懂太平间。然后你就去墓地。然后你就去墓地。好吧，好吧，好吧。好吧，墓地。好吧。那是什么？
I don't know, but just all of Ryan's phrasing too, when he's like, are he Andy has anyone, like just the way he talks, I'm like, oh my God, Ryan. And I love that Oscar just called him out, like this son of a thing. Well, Robert calls his phone, Andy answers and says he is sick.
我不知道，不过瑞安说话的腔调也真是的，当他说“安迪有没有谁，呃，就像他说话的那种方式”，我就想：“哦，天哪，瑞安。”而且我喜欢奥斯卡直接呛声回去，就像这个混蛋一样。好吧，罗伯特给他的电话打了过去，安迪接了电话，说他生病了。
But Robert says I don't care, come to work anyway. Yeah, and then Andy says, I'm just really sick and I've got the and hangs up on him. Yes, Andy hangs up and then we reveal he is standing on a beach. He says he's in Florida. He's here to get Aaron. He's like shaving on the beach. He's like standing in the ocean. Yeah, I guess he couldn't have gone to a gas station to do this. Yeah, I do.
但罗伯特说我不管，无论如何都得来上班。是的，然后安迪说：“我真的病得很重，我有……然后就把电话挂了。”是的，安迪把电话挂了，接着镜头一转，我们发现他正站在一片海滩上。他说他在佛罗里达。他是来找艾琳的。他甚至在海滩上刮胡子。他就像是站在海里一样。是的，我猜他当时不可能去加油站干这事。是的，我懂。
Or something. I don't know. He gone to a gas station to do this. Yeah, I do. Or something. I don't know. He needed to do it in the ocean water. By the way, I looked up shaving using salt water. Not recommended. I wouldn't think so. It burns. Of course. They also say don't shave your legs right before you go in the ocean water
或者别的什么地方。我不知道。他非得在海水里刮。顺便说一句，我查了一下用盐水刮胡子。不推荐。我想也是。会刺痛。当然。他们还说千万不要在下海前刮腿毛，
because salt can get in the pores and sting. I think I've made that mistake. Me too. Okay, back to Andy's talking head here in the middle of the ocean. I think I caught a little line fumble that made it into the show. I'm curious because we got a fan mail flurry about something Andy said. Okay, well I did a little mom detective work. So when Andy has this talking head, he says,
因为盐分会渗入毛孔并产生刺痛感。我想我犯过那个错误。我也是。好吧，回到安迪在海洋正中的单人访谈。我觉得我抓到了一句说漏嘴的台词，而这居然被剪进了正片里。我很想知道，因为我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝来信，都在讨论安迪说的一句话。好吧，我做了一点老妈侦探工作。所以当安迪做这个单人访谈时，他说：
I'm in Florida to get Aaron. As soon as I heard she wasn't coming back to Scranton, I jumped straight in my car and drove straight down till I hit the ocean. My heart is my map. Turns out, Tallahassee is about 200 miles inland, so I overshot a good amount. But still, not bad for a hard map, right?
“我来佛罗里达是为了找艾琳。一听说她不回斯克兰顿了，我二话不说跳进车里，一路狂飙直奔大海。我的心就是我的地图。”原来，塔拉哈西距离内陆大约有200英里，所以我开过头了相当长的一段距离。不过话说回来，对于一张仅凭内心的地图来说，这已经很不赖了吧？
Yes, okay. Our fan mail flurry, which I'm hoping you detective, but I don't know, is that the closest beach to Tallahassee is only about 40 miles inland. That's right. So if he's 200 miles away from Tallahassee, people would like to know where the heck did Andy go? Okay, I'm on it, you guys. So yes, we have discussed a little bit about Tallahassee in previous episodes, but I think they might have intended
是的，好吧。我们收到了大量粉丝来信，我希望你能当回侦探，但我不确定，他们说距离塔拉哈西最近的海滩其实只有大约40英里内陆。没错。所以如果他距离塔拉哈西有200英里，大家就想知道安迪到底去哪儿了？好吧，各位，这案子我接了！所以是的，我们在之前的剧集里稍微讨论过塔拉哈西，但我觉得他们当时想要表达的
something a little different than the way it was interpreted. Oh! So yes, the Gulf of Mexico is about 22 miles from Tallahassee. You can see water there. The truest white sandy beach on the internet. Apparently people say is St. George Island, which is about 90 miles, but but still this is not 200 miles. Right. I was curious why would the writers write this. I went to the shooting draft to see if this talking head was
可能跟实际演绎出来的有点儿不一样。哦！所以是的，墨西哥湾距离塔拉哈西大约有22英里。你在那儿能看到水。网上说最纯正的白沙海滩。显然人们说是圣乔治岛，大约有90英里，但即便如此，这也不是200英里。对的。我很奇怪为什么编剧会这么写。我翻看了拍摄剧本，想看看这段单人访谈是否
scripted the way it aired and this is what I found. Everything was the same except for this line. I overshot Tallahassee by about 200 miles. There's no mention of the word inland and I think Edith's. There's no mention of the word inland. And I think Ed is Andy was not supposed to say the word inland. It wasn't scripted. I think maybe he just said that line in the moment, and maybe that was their best take and they left it in, but it does change this talking head.
就是按照播出的剧本写的，结果我发现了这个。所有内容都一样，除了这句台词：“我开过头了，把塔拉哈西甩在后面大约200英里。”里面根本没有“内陆”这个词，而且我觉得爱德华……这里根本没有“内陆”这个词。我觉得埃德——安迪本来是不应该说“内陆”这个词的。剧本里根本没有。我想他可能只是当时顺口说出了那句台词，也许那是他们拍得最好的一条，所以就被剪进去了，但这确实改变了这段单人访谈的意思。
So it's been a lot of time on Google Maps. If you drive from Scranton, Pennsylvania, down to Florida, a straight shot down the coast, because Andy said he was driving straight down to resolve the ocean. Yeah. Well, there is one beach town that is a straight shot down from Scranton, Pennsylvania,
所以在谷歌地图上花了很多时间。如果你开车从宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿一路向南开到佛罗里达，沿着海岸线直直开下来，因为安迪说过他是径直开向大海的。是的。好吧，确实有一个海滨小镇是顺着宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿一路向南直达的，
but that is also 202 miles from Tallahassee with St. Augustine Beach, Florida. And that is my theory for where Andy is when he does this talking head. But I'm not done. Oh, I was curious. How long would it have taken Andy to drive from Scranton, Pennsylvania to St. Augustine Beach, Florida, and then over to Tallahassee? The first leg of the drive is 981 miles roughly.
但那个地方距离塔拉哈西也有202英里，那就是佛罗里达州的圣奥古斯丁海滩。这就是我对于安迪做这段单人访谈时所在位置的推测。但我还没说完呢。哦，我很好奇。安迪从宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿开车到佛罗里达州的圣奥古斯丁海滩，然后再开到塔拉哈西，大概要花多长时间？第一段行程大约是981英里。
The second part of the drive is 203 miles to correct his overshot, and it's around 1200 miles altogether and about an 18-hour drive. That got me wondering, how did Andy do this? Did he have to stay at a motel? Did he drive straight through? Well, there's a moment in deleted scenes that fills us in a little bit about how he did this drive.
开车行程的第二部分是203英里，用来纠正他开过头的地方，全程大约1200英里，开了大约18个小时。这让我很好奇，安迪是怎么做到的？他得住在汽车旅馆里吗？他是直接开过去的吗？嗯，有一个被删减的片段向我们透露了一点他是如何完成这段车程的。
You must be tired. No, actually I'm not tired. I had a 12-pack of this energy drink called Up Yours has picture of a hyena giving you the finger on the can. I feel weird. So I guess Andy got himself a case of up yours and powered through the night. Well, I mean, he's gonna tell Aaron later he didn't stop at all and she's like not even to pee. Not even to pee.
你一定累坏了吧。不，其实我不累。我喝了一打这种叫“滚蛋”的功能饮料，罐子上画着一只向你竖中指的土狼。我觉得怪怪的。所以我想安迪一定是买了一箱“滚蛋”，然后硬撑着熬过了整个夜晚。我的意思是，他待会儿会告诉艾琳他根本没停过车，然后艾琳就会说连嘘嘘都没有吗？连嘘嘘都没有。
Even though he drank all that up yours? Yeah, I don't know. Angela, this was very, very good detective work. Thank you. Now people from Florida, you might tell me there's a different beach town. That would be the first one that Andy would see, but that's the one I saw that was also because it's two things. It's got to be straight south from Scranton along the coast, but then it's also got to be
尽管他喝了那么多“滚蛋”？好吧，我不知道。安吉拉，这是一次非常非常棒的侦探工作。谢谢。现在来自佛罗里达的人可能会告诉我，还有一个不同的海滩小镇，那将是安迪看到的第一个小镇，但那是我看到的那个，这也是因为两点原因。它必须沿着海岸从斯克兰顿一直向南，但接着它还必须
around 200 miles from Tallahassee. I think this was excellent work. I can tell you where we actually shot this. Oh yes, where was Ed? Ed was at Will Rogers Beach. And Steve Burgess said, we just sent a small crew, a splinter unit, as they're called. It was two vans, one camera, sound, and a few props, and Ed was there about two hours.
距离塔拉hassee（塔拉哈西）大约200英里。我认为这是一项出色的工作。我可以告诉你我们实际拍摄这个场景的地方。哦，是的，埃德在哪里？埃德在威尔罗杰斯海滩。史蒂夫·伯杰斯说，我们只派了一个小团队，也就是所谓的支队。那是两辆面包车、一台摄像机、录音设备和一些道具，埃德在那里待了大约两个小时。
Well, that was a lot of Google maps for you guys. Maybe we should take a break. Because when we come back, Robert is basically going to share with everyone he's not going to do anything about Nellie's takeover. Because you know what, Jenna, sometimes the flowers arrange themselves. Exactly. We'll take a break, be right back. We're back and yeah, Robert is not going to take any action. Jim is like, what the heck is going on? The wheels are coming off the bus. I think that little where is Andy at the end of Jim's talking had I I feel like that was an improv. Do you think? I didn't
好吧，对你们来说，那可查了挺多谷歌地图的。也许我们该休息一下。因为当我们回来的时候，罗伯特基本上会和大家分享他不会对内莉的接管采取任何行动。因为你知道吗，珍娜，有时花儿自己就会排列好。没错。我们休息一下，马上回来。我们回来了，是的，罗伯特不会采取任何行动。吉姆的表情就像是，这到底是怎么回事？这车都要散架了。我觉得吉姆最后那句“安迪在哪里”的独白，我觉得那是即兴发挥。你觉得呢？我没有
look it up. I should have looked it up. I don't know. I feel like I could just tell, but I'll tell you where Andy is. Andy is in a box because I re-enopened her front door and there's a box. There's no postage on it. Yeah, it's a package. It's for Aaron. And Andy is going to pop out with flowers and he's singing, Sign Sealed and Delivered. I love that no one in the house like saw him doing any shenanigans in the front yard. You know this was not a simple like, oh, just set a box down. It was like, I'm going to put a box, then I'm a climb in it, then I'm going to try to tape it. Like, what's happening in the front yard?
去查。我本该去查一下的。我不知道。我觉得我一眼就能看出来，不过我来告诉你安迪在哪里。安迪在一个盒子里，因为我重新打开了她的前门，那里有一个箱子。上面没有邮资。是的，是一个包裹。是给艾琳的。然后安迪会带着鲜花从里面跳出来，唱着《已签字、已封口、已送达》。我喜欢屋里的任何人都没有看到他在前院搞什么恶作剧。你知道这可不是什么简单的“哦，随便放个箱子在地上”的事。就像是，我要放一个箱子，然后我要爬进去，然后我要试着把它用胶带封上。前院里到底在发生什么啊？
You know, I didn't think about the moment before. Moment before is what we're asked to imagine before we go on stage as an actor. Yes. This is a big part of acting crap. Crap. Yeah. What was my moment before? I appeared. In my mind, Andy had stuff. There was like a roll of tape somewhere. What was my moment before? I appeared. In my mind, Andy had stuff. There was like a roll of tape somewhere. There was, yeah, is it in? How did he do it?
你知道的，我之前没想过“之前的时刻”。“之前的时刻”就是作为一个演员在登台前被要求想象的事情。是的。这是表演的核心部分。废话。是的。我出现之前的时刻是什么？在我的脑海里，安迪带了东西。某处有卷胶带之类的东西。我出现之前的时刻是什么？在我的脑海里，安迪带了东西。某处有卷胶带之类的东西。确实有，是的，它在里面吗？他是怎么做到的？
I don't know. I get hung up on the moment before. Well, this moment before is a mystery. We had a fan question from Victoria K. and Wisconsin who wanted to know how much did we have to pay for the rights for Science-Yield and Delivered and the answer was $20,000. It was a pricey song. However, I looked up a little history on Science-Yield and Delivered and I'm going to say it's worth every penny. This song was originally released in 1970 and it is a
我不知道。我一直纠结于那个之前的时刻。好吧，这个之前的时刻是个谜。我们有一个来自威斯康星州维多利亚·K的粉丝提问，她想知道我们为《已签字、已封口与已送达》的版权支付了多少钱，答案是2万美元。这是一首很贵的歌。不过，我查了一下《已签字、已封口与已送达》的历史，我要说它绝对物有所值。这首歌最初发行于1970年，它是一首
Motown Classic. It has a really interesting history because Stevie Wonder co-wrote this song with his wife, Surita Wright. They're no longer married, but after this song was released, they married just weeks later. He also co-wrote it with an occasional collaborator named Lee Garrett, but the song carries an additional co-writing credit for Stevie Wonder's mother, the late Lula May Hardaway, because Stevie Wonder said that she said the title phrase when she heard him working on the song's melody. Oh, that's so cool. And this was also a really significant song because it was the first single on which Stevie
摩城经典。它有着一段非常有趣的经历，因为史蒂夫·旺达是和他的妻子苏里塔·赖特共同创作了这首歌。他们现在已经不再是夫妻了，但在歌曲发行后短短几周，他们就结婚了。他还与一个偶尔合作的词曲作者李·加勒特共同创作了这首歌，但这首歌还有一个额外的词曲创作署名，属于史蒂夫·旺达的母亲、已故的露拉·梅·哈达威，因为史蒂夫·旺达说，当他听到自己创作这首歌的旋律时，母亲说出了这首歌的标题短语。哦，太酷了。而且这首歌也非常具有历史意义，因为它是史蒂夫·旺达作为制作人署名的第一首单曲，也是他第一首获得格莱美提名的歌曲。这是一首有着深厚历史底蕴的歌。底蕴深厚。而安迪要从箱子里跳出来，把它唱给艾琳听。是的。带着花。还有一件事。他得带着花爬进箱子里。
Wonder was listed as a producer and it's also his first to win a Grammy nomination. It's a song with a lot of history. A lot of history. And Andy is going to jump out of a box and sing it to Aaron. Yep. With flowers. That's the other thing. He had to crawl in the box with flowers.
他得停下来买个箱子。他得买一支马克笔，因为他必须在箱子外面写字。还有胶带。是用胶带封上的吗？还是说，你是怎么做到的，他是从底部进去的吗？也许吧。他是从底部进去的。现在，也许他在邓德穆弗林有一些这样的物资，
He had to stop and get a box. He had to get a sharpie because he had to write on the outside of the box. And tape. Is it taped or is it, how do you, did he get in from the bottom? Maybe. He got in from the bottom. Now maybe he had some of these supplies at Dundercut,
但看起来他真的是直接跑出去的。是的，看起来他并不像是顺便拿了装箱子的物资。不，我想这可能是他在喝“滚蛋”时想到的一个主意。是的，在他出发12小时之后。好吧，一进屋，安迪就会告诉艾琳他爱她，他想和她在一起。
but it really looked like he just ran right out. Yeah, it didn't look like he grabbed supplies for a box. No, I think this was maybe an idea he had while he was drinking the up yours. Yeah, 12 hours into his draft. Well, once in the house, Andy is gonna tell Aaron that he loves her and he wants to be with her.
他想厮守在一起，他是来带她回斯克兰顿的。艾琳说，戒指呢，兰斯洛特？我太喜欢这句台词了。艾琳说，你知道吗，谢谢你，安迪，但我——戒指呢？兰斯洛特。我太喜欢这句台词了。艾琳说，你知道吗，谢谢你，安迪，但我不会跟你走的。什么？什么？
He wants to be together and he's there to take her home to Scranton. Irene says, where's the ring, Lance a lot? I loved that line. And Aaron says, you know what, thanks, Andy, but I the ring? Lance a lot. I loved that line. And Aaron says, you know what, thanks, Andy, but I'm not gonna go with you. What? What?
我们能在这里打几张胡扯牌吗？我的意思是，她爱他。是的，他一路开车到这里。这是她表现得像“不，没那么喜欢”的时刻。这就是如果他们用我的话，他们就会失去我，因为我不需要这一切。就像，你们的关系里有这么多的猫鼠游戏。
Can we play a few bulls*** cards here? I mean, she's in love with him. Yeah, he drives all the way there. This is her moment to be like, nah, not so much. This is where, if they'd had me, they would have lost me, because I don't need all this. Like, there's this much cat and mouse in your relationship.
那就别这样，真的。你不能让你的整段关系都在等待、等待、等待别人来追你，而当他们真的这么做时，你却用拒绝他们来惩罚他们。我们不需要这种死循环。不，那不是幸福的生活。我得说，我觉得杰西卡身上没有那种循环。当然，杰西卡身上没有那种循环。我知道。我们显然需要T恤衫，上面印着“杰西卡战队”。因为我们是，有几个人向我们指出，我们显然是杰西卡战队。很抱歉我们是。回到斯克兰顿，内莉将主持一场会议，会议的主题是“这到底是怎么回事？”这到底是怎么回事？我很乐意去参加
Just don't do it, like truly. You can't spend your whole relationship with someone just waiting and waiting and waiting for them to chase you, and then when they do, you punish them by rejecting them. That's a cycle we don't need. No, that's not a happy life. I have to say, I don't think there's that cycle with Jessica. Of course, there's not that cycle with Jessica. I know. We clearly need T-shirts that say team house. Because we are, we've had a few people point out to us that we are clearly team Jessica. Sorry we are. Back in Scranton, Nelly is going to lead a conference for a meeting called what is going on? What is going on? I would love to sit
一场名叫“这到底是怎么回事”的会议。这挺搞笑的。是的，她问大家，有人知道发生了什么吗？凯文和几个人举起了手。他们会说什么呢？我真希望当时能点到他们。我的角色举起了手。我想我当时只是好玩才那么做的。埃姆斯维尔·马丁会说些什么呢？好吧，内莉点名了凯文。她要猜他的名字。她要叫他春博（Chumbo）。这让我很好奇，春博是一个名字吗？在我们的剧本里，这明显是个笑话，但真的有人叫春博吗？我可没好奇这个，珍娜。我确实对地图感到好奇，但我知道你在名字部门有些什么收获。
in a meeting called what is going on. It's pretty funny. Yes, she asks everyone does anyone know what's going on? Kevin and a few people raise their hands. What are they gonna say? I wish we could have called on them. My character raises her hand. I think I just did it just for fun. What is Amesville Martin gonna say? Well, Nelly calls on Kevin. She's gonna guess his name. She's gonna call him Chumbo. This made me wonder is Chumbo a name. It's clearly meant as a joke in our script, but is anyone named Chumbo? I did not wonder about this, Jenna. I did wonder about maps, but I know what you got in the name
好吧，根据城市词典（Urban Dictionary），这是一个俚语，在同性恋群体中用来形容一个极其笔直的直男。哦，我给我的一个同性恋朋友打了电话来查证这件事。够了。住手。这是最典型的妈妈时刻。我知道。孩子们，听着，我给我的同性恋朋友打了电话，他是这么说的。好吧，我们从大学起就是朋友了，所以我觉得我可以带着这个研究问题打电话给他。
department. Well, according to the Urban Dictionary, it is a slang term that is used in the gay community to describe a ridiculously straight man. Oh, I called a gay friend of mine to check this out. You stop it. Stop. This is the most mom moment. I know. Kids, listen, I called my gay friend and here's what he said. Well, we've been friends since college, so I felt like I could call him with this research question.
他说，珍娜，我从来没听说过这个词，但我已经50多岁了，我并不总是能紧跟时尚年轻同性恋群体的脉搏。有可能春博这个词一直都在被大家使用。他说，我没用过。但是，是的，根据城市词典，春博往往是那些好色、喝啤酒、吃牛排、看美式橄榄球的异性恋至上主义者。
And he said, Jenna, I've never heard it, but I'm in my 50s, and I don't, I don't always have my finger on the pulse of the hip, younger gay community. It could be that Chumbo is being thrown out all the time. He said, I've not used it. But yeah, according to Urban Dictionary, Chumbo's tend to be womanizing, beer drinking, steak eating, American football watching heterosexists.
异性恋至上主义者意味着你必须具备所有这些特征，然后，我猜，还得恐同。哦，是的。哦，我明白了。是的，那就是个春博。我不知道。根据剑桥词典，春博的意思是铅。铅就像是LED（发光二极管）那样的铅。铅作为一种材料，就像铅中毒一样。没错。好吧。是的，铅漆。是的，春博。
heterosexist would mean that you have to be all those things and then also, I guess, homophobic. Oh, yeah. Oh, I see. Yeah, that's a chumbo. I don't know. According to the Cambridge dictionary, chumbo means lead. Lead like LED. Lead as in the material, like lead poisoning. Right. Okay. Yes, lead paint. Yeah, chumbo.
在葡萄牙语里，它的意思是仙人掌果。请给我来一个春博，配我的早餐，好吗？我想要一份春博沙拉。好吧。还有一件事，如果你把“春博”这个名字输入meaningslike.com，这是一个告诉你名字含义的网站，它上面有一个定义。它说，名叫春博的人代表着雄心勃勃的独立性、力量、可靠性和专业精神。听起来像个虚假的网站。
In Portuguese, it means prickly pear. Could I get a chumbo, please, with my breakfast? I would like a chumbo salad. Okay. One more thing, if you put the name chumbo into meaningslike.com, this is a website that tells you the meaning of names, it says a definition. It says people named chumbo represent ambitious independence, strength, reliability, and professionalism. That sounds like a bogus website.
我觉得我也可以把我的名字输进去。我输入了雷吉娜。雷吉娜的意思是女王。我可没说那个。我觉得我甚至可以输入像“臭鞋”这样的词。然后它就会说，这是一个能够领导国家的杰出名字。是的，我确实有这种感觉。我也找不到任何叫春博的名人，但我确实偶尔能找到把春博当作姓氏的情况。好吧。回到诸如
I feel like I could put my name in. And I put in Regina. Regina means queen. I didn't say that. I feel like I could put in like stinky shoe. And it would say, this is a name that would lead nation. Yes, I did get that feeling. I also can find anyone with the first name chumbo, but I did find chumbo as a last name a few times. Okay. Back in like
古老年代。古老年代。确实有一些叫春博的人。所以查尔斯·春博。是的。好吧。查尔斯·春博吃了一个仙人掌果。一个仙人掌果在葡萄牙。是的。还戴着铅戒指。我猜。并且看着橄榄球。没错。
Yold and times. Yold and times. There were some chumbo's. So Charles' chumbo. Yeah. Okay. Charles' chumbo ate a prickly pear. A prickly pear and Portugal. Yes. While wearing a lead ring. I guess. And watching football. Exactly.
我们这是怎么了？我不知道。我们就像安迪一样。我们有点神志不清了。我们神志不清了。好吧，内莉要向春博和在座的其他人解释，她是新经理。
What has happened to us? I don't know. We're like Andy. We're loopy. We're loopy. Okay. Well, Nelly is going to explain to Chumbo and everyone else that she is the new manager.
潘问罗伯特这是不是真的。而罗伯特正在做他常做的那种事，对明显只是把他当成娱乐的生活，他现在终于觉得有乐子了。他在睡梦中都觉得无聊，但什么？发生了什么？有什么事正在发生？有什么事正在发生。
Pam asks Robert if this is true. And Robert is doing that thing that he does where clearly life is just like entertainment for him. And now he's finally entertained. He's been bored in his sleep, but what? What's happening? Something's happening? Something's happening.
罗伯特说，在一个充满常规和节奏的世界里，凯文吃了别人的午餐，菲利斯有了一条新项链。但这个女人是谁？他入戏了。他就像是，我已经买好票了。我要看这场戏。所以这是另一个
Robert says in a world of routines and rhythms, Kevin eats someone's lunch, Phyllis has a new necklace. But who is this woman? He's in. He's like, I've just bought my ticket. I'm gonna watch this show. So this was the other talking head
在补拍中稍后添加的独白。罗伯特在邓德穆弗林招牌外的这段独白。好吧，我觉得我们需要它。我也这么觉得，因为即使有了这段独白，我读过的很多文章还是觉得罗伯特对内莉的这次接管如此纵容有点牵强。
that was added later in reshoots. This Robert talking head outside by the Dunder Mifflin sign. Well, I think we needed it. I do too, because even with this talking head, a lot of the articles that I read thought it was a little bit of a stretch that Robert was so permissive of this takeover by Nelly.
没错。这某种程度上解释了原因。正如你所说，这是为了他的娱乐。世界就是来娱乐他的。是的。但人们对这一点还是有点难以接受。好吧，内莉迎来了她自己创立的第一个会议室会议。
Right. This kind of explains it. Like you said, it's for his entertainment. The world is here to entertain him. Yeah. But people had a little bit of a hard time with that. Well, here Nelly is in her first ever conference from meeting that she set up.
她要告诉大家她觉得受到了不尊重。而她所做的一切只是想了解每个人。我很抱歉，但他们别无选择。她不得不进行绩效考核。哦，我忘了一件事。什么？你注意到关于整个会议室场景的什么事情了吗？你看到我们当时坐在哪里了吗？
And she's going to tell people she feels disrespected. And all she's trying to do is get to know everyone. And I'm sorry, but they've left her no choice. She's going to have to conduct performance reviews. Oh, I forgot to say something. What? Did you notice anything about this whole conference room scene? Did you see where we were sitting?
哦，我们坐着！是的，我们挨得很近。我注意到了。我注意到了。已经过去这么久了，我简直不敢相信他们竟然能这样。是的，我完全是想提起这个。看，你们坐在一起。我知道。
Oh, we were sitting! Yes, we were next to each other. I noticed that. I noticed that. It's been so long, I can't believe they must do it. Yeah, I totally meant to bring that up. See you did next to each other. I know.
但你说得对。她要开始进行绩效考核了，她说微笑会带来很大的帮助。所以考虑一下微笑吧。顺便说一句，她的绩效考核完全是基于她的第一印象。是的，不是根据任何工作表现。我们现在要从
But you're right. She's going to start conducting performance reviews and she says smiling goes a long way. So think about smiling. Her performance reviews, by the way, are based solely on her first impressions. Yeah, not on any performance. We're now going to get a real disgusting lunch
艾琳那里看到一顿真正令人作呕的午餐，热狗。她一直在重复使用煮热狗的水，真的给它增添了很多风味。这只会越来越好，她说。这个场景里还有更多内容。都在被删减的片段里。他们把格伦写得像个彻头彻尾的混蛋。我想他们不得不收敛一点。我喜欢看格伦在这个场景里的表现。我喜欢他的所有面部表情。我全盘接受了。他在被删减的片段里有一句台词，当时大家都在说话，他说，有人有什么我可以读的东西吗？
from Erin, hot dogs. She's been reusing the hot dog water, really gives it a lot more flavor. It's only gonna get better, she says. There's so much more to this scene. It's indelated scenes. They wrote Glenn as such an ass bull. I think they had to dial it back. I loved watching Glenn in this scene. I loved all of his facial expressions. I was eating it up. He has a line in deleted scenes where they're all talking and he goes, does anyone have anything I can read
因为我对这个对话不感兴趣。我不是为了这个来的。关于格伦，也就是格伦这个角色，我有一点小花絮。好的。你知道，有时当编剧们编写剧本的早期版本时，他们会把朋友的名字或者他们想象中适合这个角色的某个人的名字写进去。是的。所以在早期这个剧本的大纲里，写着：
because I'm not into this conversation. I'm not here for it. I have a little trivia about Glenn, the character of Glenn. Okay. You know, sometimes when the writers would write early versions of the script, they would put in the name of a friend or someone that they imagined in the role. Yeah. So in the early outline for this script, it said,
切到艾琳45岁的儿子，菲尔·罗森塔尔。啊！这太搞笑了。但艾琳的孙子实际上是由非常搞笑的布拉德·莫里斯扮演的。他是芝加哥第二城（Second City）喜剧剧团的成员。他还在《熟女镇》（Cougar Town）和《善地》（The Good Place）中扮演过常驻角色。好吧，他真的很搞笑。在被删减的片段里，他的角色还有很多戏份。
cut to Irene's 45-year-old son, Phil Rosenthal. Ah! That's very funny. But Irene's grandson was actually played by the very funny Brad Morris. He was a member of Second City Chicago. He's also had recurring roles on Cougar Town and The Good Place. Well, he's really funny. There's a lot more of his character, Indeleted Scenes.
他简直就是个真正的混蛋，但极其搞笑。我确实很喜欢这个场景里的这一点。艾琳当面质问安迪。她说，那么，安德鲁，你那个瘦瘦的、留着棕色头发的女朋友杰西卡，对你去看望前女友作何感想？嗯哼。安迪说，我们其实已经不怎么约会了。所以基本上，我的意思是，我只需要画好几个T字
He's just a real jerk, but it's hilarious. I do love that in this scene. Irene calls Andy out. She says, so Andrew, how does your skinny, brunette girlfriend Jessica feel about you visiting your ex girlfriend? Mm-hmm. Andy says, we're not really dating anymore. So basically, I mean, I just have to cross a few teas
，并在几个I字上点上圆点。然后艾琳就像是，等等，所以你是来接我的，但你居然还有一个女朋友？安迪。安迪！是的。安迪在这个场景之后本来应该有一段独白。在被删减的片段里。我想让你们听听。艾琳对杰西卡的事一清二楚，这意味着艾琳一直在谈论我。
and dot a few eyes. And Aaron's like, wait, so you came to get me and you still have a girlfriend? Andy. Andy! Yeah. Andy would have had a talking head after this scene. It's in deleted scenes. I want you to hear it. Irene knows all about Jessica, which means that Aaron has been talking about me a lot.
这听起来像是一个已经放下过去的人吗？嗯。你甚至还想吃甜点吗？还是你还在遵循南海滩饮食法？所以，艾琳显然一直在相当多地谈论他，但我也觉得很有趣的是，我们了解到他在遵循南海滩饮食法。什么是南海滩饮食法？我不记得了。
Does that sound like someone has moved on? Hmm. Do you even want dessert? Or are you still doing South Beach? So, Aaron's clearly been talking about him quite a bit, but also I did think it was funny that we learned he's on South Beach diet. What's the South Beach diet? I can't remember.
我知道这曾是一种巨大的风潮。这些时不时就会出现的饮食法对我觉得太搞笑了，对吧？我现在在吃什么？我觉得我记得我妈有那本书，但我到底不吃什么呢，我猜。我刚用谷歌搜了一下。所以这是一种由心脏病专家创造的流行饮食法。当时有一本书，叫《南海滩饮食》。
I know it was like a big fad. It's so funny to me these diets that like come around, right? What am I eating now? I feel like I remember my mom had the book, but what am I not eating, I guess. Here, I googled it. So it was a popular diet created by a cardiologist. There was a book, the South Beach Diet.
我想基本上这种饮食法就是低碳水化合物，高蛋白质和健康脂肪。所以这就是所有其他的饮食法嘛。我的意思是，那不就是每一种饮食法吗？难道生酮饮食（paleo）不是一回事吗？我甚至都不知道。上面说，如果你在遵循南海滩饮食法，你要专注于吃精瘦蛋白质，比如
And I guess basically this diet is lower in carbs and higher in protein and healthy fats. So it's just every other diet. I mean, that's every diet, right? Isn't that paleo? Isn't paleo the same thing? I don't even know. It says, if you were doing the South Beach diet, you focus on eating lean proteins such
海鲜、去皮家禽、瘦牛肉和大豆制品。你还可以吃高纤维蔬菜、低脂奶制品以及包含牛油果、坚果和种子在内的健康不饱和脂肪。我要开始减肥了。你打算叫它什么？就叫“大家伙儿把好东西吃了，别再吃那些垃圾了”。这个减肥法标题是不是太长了？我的意思是，显然，它应该叫“他妈的常识”。
as seafood, skinless poultry, lean beef, and soy products. You can also eat high fiber vegetables, low fat dairy foods with healthy unsaturated fats, including avocados, nuts, and seeds. I'm going to start a diet. What are you going to call it? Just eat the good stuff and stop eating all the junk everyone. Is that too long of a diet title? I mean, obviously, it's called just like f***ing common sense.
就像别吃。别当个笨蛋。是的，就像吃那些从地里长出来东西和精瘦蛋白质，结束。每一种饮食法都是一样的。饮食法之间根本没有区别。我们到底要用多少种不同的方式把同样的信息重新包装一遍？但接着每个人都说，哦，我在进行这种饮食，我在进行那种饮食。
Like don't eat. Don't be an idiot. Yeah, just like eat stuff that grows out of the ground and lean protein the end. Every diet is the same. There's no difference in the diets. Like how many different ways do we have to repackage the same information? But then everyone's like, oh, I'm this diet, I'm that diet.
然后就像是，哦，你在吃什么？哦，瘦肉，你在避开碳水化合物，你在吃一些新鲜蔬菜。谁能想得到呢？天哪。哦，天才时刻！来自又一次把这个写下来的人，这已经是第70次了。我发誓，我要开始减肥了。
And it's like, oh, what are you eating? Oh, lean meat, you're avoiding carbs, and you're eating some freshly-fe-vegetables. Who could have ever thought of it? Oh my God. Oh, genius moment! From whoever wrote that down again for the 70th time. I swear to God, I'm gonna start a diet.
我觉得你真该这么做，我真的觉得我想把标题定为“别当个笨蛋”。吃好东西。珍妮弗·费舍尔著的《吃好东西》。所以大概是一本两页的书。超级简单。我觉得有一页就够了。
I think you should, and I really think that I wanna pitch the title is Don't Be an Idiot. Eat good stuff. Eat good stuff by Jennifer Fisher. So like a two-page book. It's super simple. I think it's one page.
我觉得有一页就够了。也许第一段是你宣泄这种情绪的发泄。是的。然后第二段是，别当个笨蛋。然后你就大功告成了。这不难。这并不难。每个人都知道什么是好食物，什么是坏食物。
I think it's one page. Maybe the first paragraph is you venting this vent. Yeah. And then the second paragraph is, don't be an idiot. And then you're done. It's not hard. It's not hard. Everybody knows what good food and bad food is.
当我在夜里睡觉前坐在家里，吃着两碗幸运麦圈（Lucky Charms）时。我很清楚自己在做什么。我不需要一本书来告诉我这不是一个绝佳的选择。等等，你真的在这么做吗？对啊。你晚上吃两碗幸运麦圈。对。是的，因为那是无麸质麦片，然后我用椰子豆奶泡着吃。那算是你的甜食吗？哦不，我已经吃过甜食了。不，这不是我的甜食。我的意思是，甜食就是甜食。这只是你深夜的磨牙小零食。对，对。
When I am sitting at home at night right before bed, eating two bowls of lucky charms. I know what I'm doing. I don't need a book to tell me this isn't a great choice. Wait, are you doing that? Yeah. You're eating two bowls of lucky charms at night. Yeah. Yeah, because it's gluten-free cereal and then I have it with like a coconut soy milk. And is that like your dessert? Oh no, I've eaten dessert. No, it's not my dessert. I mean, dessert is dessert. This is just your late night gnawsh. Yeah, yeah.
嗯哼，好吧。你知道，我深夜的磨牙小零食以前可能是某种冰淇淋甜点。是的。关于我的那几碗麦片还有另一件事，因为我觉得我现在真的超级诚实。是吗？
Mm-hmm, okay. You know, my late night gnawsh might maybe use to have been some sort of ice cream treat. Yeah. And here's the other thing about my bowls of cereal because I feel like I'm being really honest right now. You are?
我真的、真的很诚实。你们应该直面你们自己，因为每次我这么做时，我都先做一碗麦片，然后我把所有东西都收好，然后我吃掉它，等我吃到只剩下牛奶时，我又站起来，走回去，把幸运麦圈拿出来，再撒一些进去。你为什么不直接把盒子留在外面？
I'm really, really honest. You should either face you guys because each time I do it, I make one bowl of cereal, and then I put everything away, and then I eat it, and then when I get down to just the milk, I get up again, and I go back, and I get the lucky charms out, and I sprinkle more in. Why don't you just leave the box out?
因为我不承认这将是一个两碗麦片的夜晚。好吧。你知道的，如果我把幸运麦圈收起来，这还有可能是一个一碗麦片的夜晚。如果我把盒子留在旁边，在我们停下来之前，我们可能会吃了整整三大碗。但我的意思是……你这是在给自己制造小障碍。没错。我妈以前就这么干。我妈现在还这么干。她走到食品储藏室，抓了一把薯片。她把袋子卷好，放回储藏室，然后走过去坐下，吃完手里那一小把薯片。等她吃完了，
Because I'm not admitting that it's gonna be a two bowl night. Okay. You know, there's a chance it can be a one-bowl night if I put the lucky charms away. If I leave the box out next to me, we might be three bowls deep before stop. But I'm just saying... You're making your own little obstacles. That's right. My mom used to do this. My mom still does this. She goes to the pantry and she takes a handful of chips. She rolls the bag back up, puts it in the pantry and goes and sits down and eats one handful of chips. And when she's done,
她又站起来，重复这个过程。因为她只是在吃一小把。但我的重点是这个，我不需要一本书来告诉我这不是一个好选择。我不需要读那个。我很清楚自己在做什么。当我们只吃油炸食品而几乎不吃蔬菜时，我们都很清楚自己在做什么。这就是为什么我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。
she gets up, she goes and repeats. Because she's just eating a handful. But my point is this, I don't need a book to tell me that this isn't a great choice. I don't need to read that. I know what I'm doing. We all know what we're doing when we're just eating fried foods and barely any vegetables. This is why we know. We know. We know.
我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。
We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know.
我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。我们知道。真的整整一个星期？对。你吃几碗麦片？我不知道。我没有，我没有吃很多麦片。我没有，你知道我会说什么吗？
We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know For the whole week, really? Yeah. How many balls of cereal do you have? I don't know. I don't, I don't have a lot of cereal. I don't, you know what I would say?
我不吃早餐麦片。是的。我没有。你吃多少薯片？就一把。是的。是的。我们清楚自己在做什么。
I don't have cereal for breakfast. Yeah. I don't. How many chips do you have? Just a handful. Yeah. Yeah. We know what we're doing.
刚才有点扯远了。我没想到自己对这事感触这么深。我有些能把我们拉回这一集的内容。请吧。安迪真的在试图和艾琳拉近距离。我的意思是，你注意到了吗？就像，他在试图和她搞好关系。他在床上做腿部练习，而他的手机却一直在响个不停。
That was a tangent. I didn't know I felt strongly about it. I have something getting us back onto the episode. Please. Andy really tries to bond with Irene. I mean, have you noticed this? Like, he's trying to bond with her. He's doing leg exercises on the bed while his phone keeps ringing and ringing.
嗯哼。但他也很欣赏她的家居装饰。这在被删减的片段里。我觉得这真的超级可爱。哦，我想听听。而且我们了解到了一些关于艾琳的有趣事情。艾琳，这房子真可爱。好吧。说真的，这是你自己装修的吗，因为我太喜欢了？
Mm-hmm. But he also really appreciated her home decor. It's in deleted scenes. I thought it was really cute. Oh, I want to hear it. And we learned something kind of interesting about Irene. Irene, this house is lovely. Okay. I'm serious. Did you decorate it yourself because I love it?
你真的很喜欢吗？因为所有的东西都在eBay上出售。我会发个链接给你。我太乐意了。听着，这是整集中我最喜欢的艾琳和安迪的对手戏。我知道它没有在正片中播出，但当他说“我真的很喜欢你对这个地方的改造”时，她说“好吧，我知道”，这真是太棒了。为什么她要把她整个家的东西都在eBay上卖掉？我不知道。为什么她要把她整个家的东西都在eBay上卖掉？我不知道。你知道，我在这个场景里发现了一些背景小彩蛋。其中一个来自瑞典的蒂亚·A，她说在艾琳卧室的墙上挂着一张一个穿着裙子的女孩的装裱照片。而且。那是托马斯·劳伦斯爵士的画作《红衣男孩》（Pinkie）。好吧，蒂亚，它正在eBay上出售呢。确实如此。我还注意到这个场景中电视机开着。有一个镜头是一只狗在四处走动。我问了史蒂夫·伯杰斯关于这件事的情况。他说，是的，他们为一些现成的动物素材支付了一小笔费用。
You really like it? Because everything's for sale on eBay. I'll send you a link. I would love that. Now listen, this was my favorite Irene Andy scene of the whole episode. I know it didn't make it to air, but it was so great when he says, I really like what you've done with the place and she goes, okay, I know. And why is she selling the contents of her entire home on eBay? I do not know. And why is she selling the contents of her entire home on eBay? I do not know. You know, I have a few background catches in this scene. One comes in from Thia A. in Sweden, who says that there is a framed picture of a girl in
其中既有狗也有企鹅。我第二次看的时候，注意到了企鹅。不错。是的，我不确定狗和企鹅怎么会出现在同一个画面里，但我在这个场景里发现了第三个彩蛋。安迪的手机一直在响，当他把它拿出来时，我有了一个新科技警报。
a dress on the wall of Irene's bedroom. And. And it is the Sir Thomas Lawrence painting pinky. Well, Thia, it's for sale on eBay. It is. I also noticed that the television was on in this scene. There's a shot of a dog walking around. I asked Steve Burgess about this. He said, yes, they paid a small fee for some stock animal footage.
哦，他换新手机了。安迪有一部智能手机。哦，哇，换新手机了。安迪有一部智能手机。哦，哇。你知道，在《测试商店》（Test the Store）里，吉姆还在用翻盖手机。是的。安迪有，我看到了。那就像是早期非常、非常早期的iPhone之一。但他们难道不都应该在
And it featured both dogs and penguins. The second time I watched, I noticed the penguins. Nice. Yeah, I'm not sure what they're doing in the same show, the dogs and penguins, but I have a third catch in this scene. Andy's phone keeps ringing, and when he gets it out, I have a new tec alert.
那个小三角形上接电话吗？我的意思是，赛博公司的手机。它们应该是三角形的智能手机。嗯哼。你知道的，安迪在这个场景中赛博公司的手机。它们应该是三角形的智能手机。嗯哼。你知道的，安迪在这个场景中会说他不知道怎么把手机调成静音。你有没有注意到艾琳会？
Oh, he got a new phone. Andy has a smart phone. Oh, wow got a new phone. Andy has a smartphone. Oh, wow. You know, in test the store, Jim still was using a flip phone. Yeah. Andy has, I saw it. It was like one of the very, very early iPhones. But shouldn't they all be answering phones
艾琳知道怎么把智能手机调成静音。这个属于新科技警报的设备。她知道怎么把所有东西都挂到eBay上卖。在前一集里，她还在教艾琳怎么用FaceTime。我知道。有一个被删减的片段，她在其中和安迪谈论她拥有的各种香料。然后她说，是的，她说，为了做海鲜饭（paella），我把所有东西都买了。
on the little triangle? I mean, cell phones from Saber. They should be the triangle smartphone. Uh-huh. And you know, Andy is gonna say in the scene cell phone from Saber. They should be the triangle smartphone. Uh-huh. And you know, Andy is going to say in the scene that he doesn't know how to put his phone on silent. And did you catch Irene knows how.
然后艾琳说，她是说木瓜（papaya）。艾琳接着说，不，我不是。我说的是海鲜饭。所以她有很多兴趣爱好。而且她很精明，对科技驾轻就熟。你知道，安吉拉，你之前给我们放了安迪的语音信箱。是的。我们收到了一些关于它的粉丝提问。
Irene knows how to put a smartphone on silent. This device that's new tech alert. She knows how to put everything on eBay. In the previous episode, she's telling Aaron how to FaceTime. I know. There is a deleted scene where she talks to Andy about all the different spices she has. And she goes, yeah, she goes, I bought everything to make a paella.
人们以为他是在唱某种广告歌。他们想知道，他唱的到底是什么歌？我问了史蒂夫·伯杰斯，他说那是埃德现编的。我们没有为那个旋律支付任何版权费。那只是埃德·赫尔姆斯的个人特色。我百分之百知道那是埃德现编的，因为他会在片场随兴编一些小曲子。有时候我们会一起演所有这些小段子，喜剧小段。有一天我们一起走进片场，
And Erin goes, she means papaya. And Irene goes, no, I don't. I mean paella. So she's got a lot of interests. And she smart knows her way around technology. You know, Angela, you played Andy's voicemail for us earlier. Yeah. And we got some fan questions about it.
在同一时间。就像是，我不知道我们在干什么，但我说了一些类似的话，“哦，我忘了我的雪地靴（Uggs）了”，然后他说，“你忘了你的雪地靴，得回去拿它们”或者诸如此类的话。那真是傻乎乎的。完全是。但你就是可以随口编出一首歌。好吧，安迪的手机一直在响。他继续无视它，但格伦接了电话。这就是你看到他们把格伦写得如此讨厌的地方。
People thought maybe he was singing a jingle. They wanted to know like, what song is he really singing? I asked Steve Burgess about it and he said, Ed just made it up. We didn't pay any rights for that melody. That's just an Ed Helm special. I 100% knew Ed made that up because he would make up little songs around the set. And sometimes we would do all these little bits together, comedy bits. One day we were like walking into set at
他接起电话说，直肠科。没错。那是吉姆，他说，安迪，你在哪儿？这就是吉姆得知安迪不打算回来的时候，至少在没有带上艾琳的情况下是不会回来的。他在佛罗里达。所以吉姆不得不试着团结大家对抗内莉。他说我们不能参与这些绩效考核，因为那样我们基本上就是接受她作为我们的经理。
the same time. And it was like, I don't know what we were doing, but I said something like, Oh, I forgot my uggs and he's like, you forgot your uggs, gotta go get them or whatever it was. It was something really silly. Totally. But you could just make up a song at the drop of a hat. Well, Andy's phone is going to keep ringing. He continues to ignore it, but Glenn answers it. And this is where you see some of the way they wrote him to be just so obnoxious.
德怀特说他不信任内莉。我的意思是，他甚至不会信任她去经营一个芹菜农场。是的，他有一段独白说，不会种地的人就去种芹菜。这是在对芹菜种植群体进行挖苦吗？好吧，我必须了解更多。我想他指的是，根据互联网的说法，你看到我刚才怎么做的了吗，安吉拉？
He answered the phone, Proctology. That's right. And it's Jim and he's like, Andy, where are you? And this is when Jim learns that Andy's not coming back, at least not without Aaron. He's in Florida. So Jim is going to have to try to unify the group against Nelly. He says we cannot participate in these performance reviews because then we are essentially accepting her as our manager.
我把整个互联网都标为出处了，就像你做的那样。谢谢你，因为我忘了写下我的出处。我有时知道出处，但有时有多个出处说类似的话，所以我只会说“根据互联网”。好吧，根据互联网的说法，作为一个会用谷歌搜索的女士，结果证明种植芹菜其实
Dwight says he doesn't trust Nelly. I mean, he wouldn't even trust her to run a celery farm. Yes, he has a talking head where he says those who can't farm farm celery. Is this a dig on the celery community? Well, I had to know more. I guess what he is referring to is that, according to the internet, did you see what I did there, Angela?
相当简单。它有非常具体的需求。你在春天种植它。你只需要给它大量的水，拥有肥沃的土壤，然后在秋天，你就能收获一堆芹菜。我这辈子再也不需要吃芹菜了。
I credited the whole internet, just like how you did. Thank you, because I forgot to write down my source. I know the source sometimes, but sometimes there's multiple sources that say similar things, so I just say according to the internet. All right, well, according to the internet, as a lady who Googles, it turns out it's really
乔希把它放在汤里。我只会觉得，嘿，现在我得到了一个没有味道的脆脆的东西。不能，我的意思是，拜托。没味道，芹菜是有味道的。什么味道？芹菜。它尝起来像芹菜。
quite easy to grow celery. It has very specific needs. You plant it in the spring. You just have to give it a lot of water, have a good rich soil, and then in the fall, you get a bunch of celery. I don't ever need to eat celery again for the rest of my life.
它不可能尝起来像别的什么东西，否则它就是别的东西了。它尝起来像芹菜。它尝起来什么都没有。好吧，如果你弄到一个坚果，你确定你不是在想水栗子吗？是的，我觉得它什么味道都没有。我讨厌那些。我也讨厌那些。芹菜，你知道，如果你把它压碎足够多，你可以喝到芹菜汁，但你只是把芹菜
Josh puts it in soups. I'm just like, hey, now I have a crunchy thing with no taste. Can't, I mean, come on. No, taste, celery has a taste. What's the taste? Celery. It tastes like celery.
切成两半咬上一口，我什么都尝不出来。你还记得芹菜汁狂热吗？记得。那是在2019年左右席卷了加利福尼亚。每个人都在喝他妈的芹菜汁。他们端着它到处走。装在他们那个巨大的吸管杯里。我喝过。我喝过。我当时在拍《分居在一起》（Splitting Up Together），我和奥利弗·哈德森（Oliver Hudson）。
It can't taste like something else or then it would be another thing. It tastes like celery. It tastes like nothing. Okay, if you get a nut, are you sure you're not thinking of like a water chestnut? Yes, I taste like nothing. hate those. I hate those too. Celery, you know, if you crush up enough of it, you can have celery juice, but you just chop a celery
我们经历过芹菜汁狂热。我们做过，我不知道我们为什么要这么做。这是你的“别当个笨蛋”饮食法的一部分吗？有可能。有可能。但当时有个医生，我猜。所以总有一个医生。我知道，总有一个医生。
in half and take a bite of it, I get nothing. Do you remember the celery juice craze? Yeah. That hit California in like 2019. Everybody had f***ing celery juice. They were walking around with it. And they're big sippy cup things. I did it. I did it. I was on splitting up together and me and Oliver Hudson.
我把医生打上了引号。我不知道，抱歉，那个发明了芹菜汁的医生。也许是个真正的医生。我不知道。但这个想法是，你榨新鲜的芹菜汁，一大早的第一件事，你必须空腹喝下它。听起来它必须是第一件事。
We did the celery juice craze. We did, I don't know why we would do this. Is this part of your don't be an idiot diet? It could be. It could be. But there was this doctor, I guess. So there was always a doctor. I know, there's always a doctor.
它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。它必须是第一件事。你觉得无聊了，然后你就会赶一阵潮流。是的，我曾经和伊利亚·伍德（Elijah Wood）一起演过一部剧。我在《威尔弗雷德》（Wilfred）里客串过，兰德尔·艾因霍恩（Randall Einhorn）导演了《办公室小聚》，他们在片场的一套标准做法，我第一天就学会了，那就是每个人都在做填字游戏。
I'm putting doctor in quotes. I don't know, sorry, doctor who came up with celery juice. Maybe you're a real doctor. I don't know. But the idea was that you juice fresh celery, first thing in the morning, you have to drink it on an empty stomach. It sounds like it has to be the first thing.
他们会拿到同一份《纽约时报》的填字游戏，打印出来，然后每个人一整天都在做填字游戏。而且每天难度都在增加。我们以前在片场玩过“与好友猜字”（Words with Friends），那是后来推出的。好吧，你们还在坚持减肥。我们喝过奇怪的饮料。
It has to be the first thing. Well morning, you have to drink it on an empty stomach. It sounds like it has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing.
好吧，奥利弗和我有一段时间喝过这种奇怪的茶。现在我们开始在早晨喝芹菜汁。这股狂热导致了芹菜短缺。在加利福尼亚。在加利福尼亚。是的，我去查了一篇关于它的文章。《洛杉矶时报》称销量增长了350%。价格飙升，每捆高达5美元。
It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing.
而且还有一些照片，比如农产品区，然后芹菜区是空的，因为每个人都开始，你必须在早晨榨新鲜的。这是另一件事。我本来就要在早上6点去上班，但我起得更早是为了榨芹菜汁。然后你把它喝下去，什么都没发生。
It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. It has to be the first thing. You get bored and then you do some fad. Yes, I once did a show with Elijah Wood. I had a guest start on Wilfred and Randall Einhorn directed Little Office reunion and their whole thing on their set. And I learned it the first day is everyone did crossword puzzles.
你只是，我的意思是，确实发生了点什么。但基本上什么都没发生。我的生活没有因为这份努力而发生任何改变。好吧，我要把它写进我的书里。这就是为什么我再也不需要吃芹菜的理论。我只是想说，我猜，别做傻事。别赶潮流。你知道什么是好的，你知道什么是坏的，结束。
They would get the same crossword puzzle for the New York Times they'd print it out and everyone all day long would be doing the crossword. In each day it gets harder. We used to do the words with friends on our set and that came out. Well you guys did still reduce. We did weird drinks.
她听起来就像一首给小学生写的小诗。就这么简单。就这么简单。内莉将从她的新办公室走出来。她的绩效考核要开始了。首先登场的是那个有着漂亮指甲和小脚的女人。安吉拉开始朝门口走去。
Okay, Oliver and I did this weird tea for a while. Now we started drinking celery juice in the mornings. This whole craze, it created a shortage of celery. In California. In California. Yes, I went and looked up an article on it. The LA Times said the sales increased by 350%. Prices skyrocketed to as much as $5 a bunch.
是菲利斯。不是安吉拉。是菲利斯。还有菲利斯。是菲利斯。菲利斯说，你知道吗？我觉得被一个根本不了解我的人考核让我感到很不舒服。内莉说，没关系。没关系。我来向你展示这是怎么做到的。
And there were pictures of like produce departments and then the salary part was empty because everybody started, you had to juice it fresh in the morning. This was the other thing. I was already going to work at 6 a.m., but I was getting up even earlier to juice my salary. And then you would drink it, nothing happened.
德怀特。德怀特说他同样感到不舒服。他在佛罗里达对她失去了所有的敬意。所以她直接给他加薪了。这是他应得的。德怀特显然会同意她直接给他加薪。嗯哼。这是他应得的。德怀特显然会同意他自己应得加薪，而吉姆就像是，这个加薪不是真的，德怀特。然后德怀特说，自从他们脱离金字塔（金本位）以来，钱就不是真的了。
You just, I mean, something happened. But pretty much nothing happened. Nothing in my life changed for this effort. Well, I'm putting it in my book. This is my theory on why I don't ever need to eat celery again. I'm just saying, I guess, don't do silly things. Don't do fads. You know what is good and you know what is bad, the end.
你只是，我的意思是，发生了点事。但几乎什么也没发生。我的生活没有因为这次努力而发生任何改变。好吧，我要把它写进我的书里。这就是我的理论，为什么我再也不需要吃芹菜了。我只是想说，我想，别做傻事。别赶潮流。你知道什么是好的，你知道什么是坏的，就这样。
She sounded like a poem for like an elementary child. It's that easy. It's that easy. Nelly is going to emerge from her new office. It's time for her performance reviews to start. First up is the woman with the beautiful fingernails and tiny feet. Angela starts to march towards the door.
她听起来就像写给小学生的诗。就这么简单。就这么简单。内莉将从她崭新的办公室里走出来。她的绩效考核要开始了。第一个上来的是那个有着漂亮指甲和小巧双脚的女人。安吉拉开始朝门口走去。
It's Phyllis. It's not Angela. It's Phyllis. And Phyllyllis. It's Phyllis. Phyllis says, you know what? I don't feel comfortable being reviewed by someone that doesn't even know me. Nelly says, that's fine. That's fine. I'll show you how it's done.
是菲利斯。不是安吉拉。是菲利斯。还有菲利斯。是菲利斯。菲利斯说，你知道吗？我觉得由一个根本不了解我的人来考核，让我感到很不自在。内莉说，没关系。没关系。我来向你展示这是怎么做的。
Dwight. Dwight says he also does not feel comfortable. He lost all respect for her in Florida. So she just offers him a raise. He deserves it. Dwight obviously is going to agree just offers him a raise. Mm-hmm. He deserves it. Dwight obviously is going to agree that he deserves a raise, and Jim's like the raise isn't real Dwight. And Dwight says money isn't real since they got off the gold standard.
德怀特。德怀特说他也感到不自在。他在佛罗里达对她失去了所有的尊重。于是她直接提出给他加薪。他应得的。德怀特显然会同意——直接提出给他加薪。嗯哼。他应得的。德怀特显然会同意他理应加薪，而吉姆却说加薪不是真的，德怀特。德怀特说自从他们脱离金本位以来，钱就不是真的。
And then he's going to start negotiating with Nelly about his raise. He demands 5%. She says, not good enough, 7%. And then he says, no, 6%. I know my worth. I loved that. Well, Phyllis now sees where this is going. So she's like, yeah, I'll get a review. Nelly tells Phyllis that she's impressed
然后他开始和内莉谈加薪的事。他要求加5%。她说，不够，7%。然后他说，不，6%。我知道我的价值。我很喜欢这个。好吧，菲yllis现在看出事情的发展方向了。所以她说，好吧，我要争取做个考核。内莉告诉菲yllis她对她克服恐惧
with how she conquered her fear. She even likes how she sits. So guess what, you get a race. I guess that was a good first impression. Jim is going to go into the conference room and speak to Robert. He wants to make sure Robert knows that Nelly is just basically handing out raises and Robert's like, oh, I guess you want one. So you can take the kids to Disney Town.
的表现印象深刻。她甚至喜欢她坐着的姿势。所以你猜怎么着，你加薪了。我想那是个很好的第一印象。吉姆要走进会议室跟罗伯特谈谈。他想确保罗伯特知道内莉基本上是在随便发加薪，而罗伯特却说，哦，我猜你也想要一个。这样你就能带孩子们去迪士尼小镇了。
Yeah. He wants to give Jim a metaphor. And the choices are nature metaphor or sexual metaphor. The nature metaphor includes animals having sex. Yeah. The sex metaphor is that all life is sex and all sex is competition. There are no rules.
是的。他想给吉姆一个比喻。选项有自然比喻或性比喻。自然比喻包括动物交配。是的。性比喻则是所有生命都是性，所有的性都是竞争。这里没有规则。
And Charles Darwin ultimately decides who the manager is. I summed it up. That's how I guess Robert feels. Robert talks about sex a lot. Yeah. It's really the lens through which he looks at the world. Mm-hmm. Well, thank you for summing that up. Yeah, Jim is speechless. And Nelly is giving Kelly an hour raise. So many raises. And now Dwight, he's sort of taking this all in. He's like, you know what? Nelly's right. So he inspired by her, marches over to Darrell's office,
查尔斯·达尔文最终决定谁来当经理。我总结了一下。我想罗伯特就是这么觉得的。罗伯特经常谈论性。是的。这确实是他看待世界的视角。嗯嗯。好吧，谢谢你做了这个总结。是的，吉姆无言以对。内莉给凯利加了一个小时的工资。加薪太多了。现在德怀特，他基本上把这一切都看在眼里。他说，你知道吗？内莉是对的。所以他受她启发，大步走到达尔尔的办公室，
and says, hey, this is my office now. And Darrell's like, no. And Dwight's like, yeah. And then Darrell literally drags him out by his hair. Dwight's like no. And Dwight's like yeah. And then Darryl literally drags him out by his hair. Dwight's like, well, thought I accept the outcome. And during all of this, Creed has taken Dwight's desk. So Dwight actually lost a desk in this scenario. You know what I would have liked is if they would have held on to that. And then for like the rest of the season, Dwight was in the corner and Creed was across from him. Oh, that would be pretty great. And Dwight just keeps waiting for Creed to get up.
说，嘿，这现在是我的办公室了。达尔尔说，不。德怀特说，对。然后达尔尔直接拽着他的头发把他拖了出去。德怀特说，不，德怀特说，对。然后达尔尔直接拽着他的头发把他拖了出去。德怀特说，好吧，我觉得我接受这个结果。而在这期间，克里德占了德怀特的办公桌。所以德怀特在这个情况下实际上失去了一张办公桌。你知道我希望看到的是什么吗，如果他们能坚持住那个设定。然后接下来的整整一季，德怀特都坐在角落里，而克里德就坐在他对面。哦，那太棒了。而且德怀特一直在等克里德站起来。
Yes, I wish I would have become a runner. Back in Florida, Andy is fixing Irene's fountain. And I spotted some birds of paradise for you, Angela. I spotted them too. It's a dolphin fountain. Aaron says she's heard they're really beautiful when they work. Andy's been kind of hanging around, maybe hoping that Aaron's going to change her mind. He had the hot dog lunch, he did the leg exercises, he's fixing the fountain.
是的，我希望我能成为一名跑步者。回到佛罗里达，安迪正在修理艾琳的喷泉。我为你物色了一些极乐鸟花，安吉拉。我也发现了。那是个海豚喷泉。艾伦说她听说这些花在盛开时真的很漂亮。安迪一直在附近晃悠，也许是希望艾伦能回心转意。他吃了热狗午餐，做了腿部练习，他在修喷泉。
But Aaron's going to come and confront him. I would like to just point out something. In my opinion, this scene where Aaron says, look, I care about you, but you know, you hurt me. And he said, well, you you hurt me. And he said, well, you also hurt me. And she goes, no, but you hurt me more times. I had to watch you date other people. You had to reject me over and over. I thought this scene was maybe the first time in so many episodes. Where Aaron just seemed like a real person, a very grounded person. Yes, not a caricature who doesn't know what papaya is. Do you know what I mean?
但是艾伦要来找他当面对质了。我想指出一件事。在我看来，在这个场景中，艾伦说，听着，我关心你，但你知道的，你伤害了我。他说，好吧，你，你伤害了我。她说，好吧，你也伤害了我。然后她说，不，但你伤害我的次数更多。我不得不看着你和别人约会。你一次又一次地拒绝我。我觉得这个场景可能是这么多集以来的第一次。艾伦看起来像个真人，一个非常脚踏实地的真人。是的，而不是一个不知道木瓜是什么的脸谱化角色。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, I do. And I really liked at least performance in this scene. I did too. It was very real. I had a lot of empathy for Erin. This is when I'm like, okay, in this moment, I root for Erin a little, right? Because all the other times she didn't sound like a real person and Jessica seemed real.
是的，我明白。我真的很喜欢蕾丝在这个场景里的表演。我也喜欢。非常真实。我对艾伦产生了强烈的共鸣。这时候我就想，好吧，在这个时刻，我稍微支持一下艾伦，对吧？因为所有其他时候她听起来都不像真人，而杰西卡看起来很真实。
Well, they're going to hug and Andy's going to leave. But then Aaron is going to be so easily influenced. Irene is going to say you're making a terrible mistake. That guy seemed great. Even though she was being a real bee to him. Yeah. She was just trying to protect Aaron, but now she's like, you should go. You should go. And just to finish up this storyline, I guess. Andy's driving away, and Aaron is gonna come running out of the house, screaming, I love you. She runs up to a Prius. She's like, don't leave. I love you. Wrong Prius. But then she finds him
好吧，他们要拥抱了，安迪要离开了。但接着艾伦又太容易被影响了。艾琳会说你犯了一个可怕的错误。那个家伙看起来很棒。尽管她之前对安迪真的很刻薄。是的。她只是想保护艾伦，但现在她却说，你应该去。你应该去。为了给这条故事线画个句号吧，我想。安迪正在开车离开，而艾伦从房子里跑了出来，大喊着我爱你。她跑向一辆普锐斯。她说，别走。我爱你。找错普锐斯了。但接着她找到了他，
and they have an embrace in the middle of this intersection. And they're going to drive off in the sunset together. Her without any of the things she brought to Florida. I am assuming she had a suitcase for her time working for Saber clothing. toothbrush. There's no rush, right? They could have gone back to the house for that bag pretty easily. There wasn't this scene a lot of driving choreography. I was very impressed. We had to shut down the street. There was the wrong Prius. There's two cars that drive by honking. I asked Steve Burgess about it. I mean, this is complicated stuff. For us, this felt like a giant car chase fast in the furious.
他们在这个十字路口中间拥抱了。然后他们将一起驶向夕阳。她没有带任何来佛罗里达时带的东西。我猜她为在萨伯服装公司工作的那段时光准备了一个手提箱。牙刷。不着急，对吧？他们完全可以很容易地回到房子里去拿那个包。这个场景里不是有很多驾驶编排吗？我印象非常深刻。我们不得不封锁这条街道。有找错的普锐斯。有两辆车按着喇叭开过去。我问过史蒂夫·伯吉斯关于这事。我的意思是，这很复杂。对我们来说，这感觉就像是一场惊心动魄的《速度与激情》式追车大戏。
Yeah, exactly. Safety meeting. Oh, for sure. Steve Burgess said we got the extra Prius from the transport department. He's not sure who was driving it, but one of the cars was driven by our stand-in Steven Sox. He was one of the honkers. by our stand-in Steven Sox.
对，没错。安全会议。哦，肯定的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们从运输部门调来了一辆备用普锐斯。他不确定是谁开的，但其中一辆车是由我们的替身演员史蒂文·索克斯开的。他就是按喇叭的人之一。由我们的替身演员史蒂文·索克斯开的。
He was one of the honkers. Nice. I know, go, Steven. Yeah. Well, back at Dundermit Flynn, Nelly is now going to win over Pam. She's going to tell Pam, basically, that she's fantastic and deserves a nap. Yeah. And, you know, it made me think.
他就是按喇叭的人之一。太棒了。我知道，加油，史蒂文。好吧，回到邓德米夫林，内莉现在要赢得帕姆的好感了。她基本上要告诉帕姆，她太棒了，值得睡个午觉。是的。而且，你知道，这让我思考。
I mean, I know Nelly's's kind of coming out of La Fille to hear this episode, but she's really good at reading her employees. She's really good at knowing what they each want and how to butter them up. Isn't that a good manager? You're so right, Angela. I mean, I know she doesn't know the company or anything else she's talking about, but she seems to know how to relate one-on-one with people.
我的意思是，我知道内莉在这集里有点像是从天而降，但她真的很擅长揣摩她的员工。她非常擅长了解他们每个人想要什么以及如何拍他们的马屁。这难道不是一个好经理吗？你说得太对了，安吉拉。我的意思是，我知道她不了解公司或她谈论的任何其他事情，但她似乎知道如何与人们进行一对一的交流。
She knows people. Yep. And so did Michael. That's right. Did you notice that when she gets the pillow and blanket out of the little credenza, did you think that was like a Cornell blanket and pillow? They were red.
她懂人性。是的。迈克尔也是。没错。你有没有注意到，当她从小壁橱里拿出枕头和毯子时，你觉得那就像是康奈尔大学的毯子和枕头吗？它们是红色的。
And also, Nelly didn't arrive with a pillow and blanket, right? Where did she get this pillow and blanket? Has Andy been taking naps in his office? Maybe, but I did notice the filing cabinet behind the desk that normally has chauches on it. There was nothing on it. She had cleared it. I saw that, too.
而且，内莉来的时候也没有带枕头和毯子，对吧？她从哪弄来这个枕头和毯子的？安迪一直在办公室里睡午觉吗？也许吧，但我确实注意到办公桌后面的文件柜，上面通常放着小雕像。上面什么都没有。她把它清理干净了。我也看到了。
Well, Nelly's tactics have worked on everyone, but Jim. He's very resistant. No, he says, you know, you're not the manager, Nelly, and she says, I am if you believe I am, just like Tinkerbell, you just have to believe. Just believe. And then she starts sort of doing this thing where like if people don't believe Tinkerbell's gonna die,
好吧，内莉的策略对除了吉姆以外的所有人都管用。他非常抗拒。不，他说，你知道的，你不是经理，内莉，而她说，只要你相信我是，我就是，就像奇妙仙子一样，你只需要相信。只要相信。然后她开始做这样一件事，就好像如果人们不相信奇妙仙子就会死，
well that's what happens in Peter Pan. Right, but like she's acting it out in the office. That's yeah, that's what they do, like in the stage show Peter Pan. Right. But like, she's acting it out in the office. That's, yeah, that's what they do. Like in the stage show, like Tinker Bell is like dying. But then if you clap really loud in the audience, then she comes back. Oh gosh. That's the bit.
好吧，小飞侠里就是这么演的。对，但她是在办公室里把这一幕演出来了。对，是的，他们就是这么做的，就像在舞台剧《小飞侠》里一样。对。但她是在办公室里演出来的。没错，是的，他们就是这么做的。就像在舞台剧里一样，奇妙仙子快要死了。但是如果你在观众席里大声鼓掌，她就会复活。哦天哪。这就是那个桥段。
Okay, I haven't seen this on stage. I just saw actually Peter Pan goes wrong. Oh, Isabel Wittensall that. It's so funny. We saw it on Broadway in Ellie Kemper was the narrator. We went through it. But we said she was filling in as the narrator. My daughter and I went.
好吧，我没在舞台上看过这个。其实我只看过《彼得潘搞砸了》。哦，伊莎贝尔·维滕肖尔演的那个。太搞笑了。我们在百老汇看过，艾莉·坎珀是旁白。我们看过了。但我们说她是临时顶替担任旁白的。我和我女儿一起去的。
It was so cool and we got to go backstage after the show, you know, because Ellie had done it. But it's this great troupe of British performers and they do Peter Pan goes wrong. But this is how I know. This is why it's so fresh in my mind. Now I understand how Tinkerbell works. Now I understand.
太酷了，演出结束后我们还去了后台，你知道的，因为艾莉演过。但这是一个非常棒的英国表演剧团，他们演了《彼得潘搞砸了》。但这正是我了解它的方式。这就是为什么它在我的脑海里依然如此新鲜。现在我明白了奇妙仙子是怎么回事了。现在我明白了。
Yeah, my daughter and a group of her friends went and saw it and they loved it. It's so cute. You know, Nelly's gonna get the whole office to cheer for her, Aula Tinkerbell. Kevin is so worried. You know, we got a fan question from Kevin, speaking of Kevin, in Shelby Township, Michigan, who says,
是的，我女儿和她的一群朋友去看过，他们非常喜欢。太可爱了。你知道的，内莉会让整个办公室都为她欢呼，就像奇妙仙子一样。凯文太担心了。你知道的，我们收到了一个来自凯文的粉丝提问，说到凯文，来自密歇根州谢尔比镇的粉丝说，
when everyone besides Jim is cheering and clapping for Nelly, who is yelling, we believe, over and over again, in the background. I really hope you're able to solve this. Well, you said, Angela, that Kevin is really worried. I think it's Kevin. So do I. It's really weird because you hear we believe and then it cuts to a shot and Kevin's just clapping. So I think they did some like interest adventure editing here, but I have an audio clip. Let's listen to it. Come on, give me your killing heart. We believe. We believe. I have a theory. What's your theory?
当除了吉姆之外的每个人都在为内莉欢呼鼓掌时，是谁在背景里一遍又一遍地喊着，我们相信？我真的希望你们能解开这个谜团。好吧，安吉拉，你说过凯文真的很担心。我觉得是凯文。我也这么觉得。这真的很奇怪，因为你听到我们相信，然后镜头切换到凯文，他只是在鼓掌。所以我认为他们在这里做了一些像趣味剪辑一样的东西，但我有一段音频剪辑。我们听听看。来吧，给我你……你在害她吗？我们相信。我们相信。我有一个理论。什么理论？
That second one really crystallized it for me. Okay. I think it's Creed. Oh, you do! The way he held out his E like that, we believe! That sounded like Creed to me. Okay, I need to hear it again. Come on, give me a're killing her? People leave. We believe.
第二个声音真的让我确定了。好吧。我觉得那是克里德。哦，你觉得是！他拉长E音的那种方式，我们相信！这听起来像是克里德。好吧，我需要再听一遍。来吧，给我一个……你在害她吗？人们离开。我们相信。
I hear it now. I think you're right, Ange. I think it's Creed. And I think that's why when we cut back to Kevin, you don't see his mouth moving and creeds off camera. Yeah. I think it's Creed. I vote Creed.
我听出来了。我觉得你说得对，安吉，我觉得是克里德。我想这就是为什么当我们切回凯文时，你看不到他的嘴在动，而克里德不在镜头里。是的。我觉得是克里德。我投克里德一票。
I looked at the script that was not scripted. No, that was a bunch of adlibs. Well, the episode is going to end with Nelly's talking head. She says she grew up poor with no education or skills. She doesn't work hard or have good ideas. And yet she walked into someone else's job for which she was ill prepared and ill-suited and got it. And that's the American dream. Anything can happen to anyone.
我看过剧本，那不是剧本里的。不，那是一堆即兴发挥。好吧，这一集将以内莉的内心独白结束。她说她在一个贫穷的环境中长大，没有受过教育，也没有技能。她不努力工作，也没有好点子。然而，她却走进了一份她准备不足、也并不适合的别人的工作岗位，并且得到了它。这就是美国梦。任何事情都可能发生任何人身上。
It's just random. And while she has this talking head, if you notice, she's walking through the office and messing with people's desks. I did see that. She removes Dwight's personal photos and puts them on Pam's desk. She takes Pam's photos of her children and puts them on Dwight's personal photos and puts them on Pam's desk. She takes Pam's photos of her children
这全凭运气。当她进行这段内心独白时，如果你注意的话，她正在办公室里走来走去，捣乱别人的办公桌。我确实看到了。她拿走德怀特的个人照片，把它们放在帕姆的桌子上。她拿走帕姆的孩子们的照片，把它们放在德怀特的个人照片上，然后放在帕姆的桌子上。她拿走帕姆孩子的照片
and puts them on Dwight's desk. She then walks over and picks up that duck that's on the file cabinet, throws it over her shoulder towards Meredith's desk. And lastly, she goes up to Phyllis's desk, drinks what's left of her coffee out of her coffee mug, grabs a bunch of papers off of her desk and puts them in the trash.
放在德怀特的桌子上。接着她走过去拿起文件柜上的那只鸭子，越过肩膀向梅雷迪思的桌子方向扔去。最后，她走到菲利斯的桌子前，喝掉咖啡杯里剩下的咖啡，从桌上抓了一把文件扔进垃圾桶。
Yeah, we're in trouble, guys. That's her management style. Dendermiflin might be in trouble. Well, I'll tell you, I don't know where this is going. I haven't watched the next episode yet. Yeah, either. I'm curious. Same.
是的，我们有麻烦了，伙计们。这就是她的管理风格。邓德米夫林可能有麻烦了。好吧，我告诉你，我不知道这会走向何方。我还没看下一集呢。是的，我也没有。我很好奇。我也是。
And we're coming to a close on season 8. I can't believe it. We're really getting close, aren't we? Yeah. Thank you Steve Burgess for your helpful information each week. Gosh, we just couldn't do the podcast without you. I love, love, love all of your insights into the production life of each episode. Yes, and I also love Steve when you just send us pictures. You know, I mean, I love your yellow lab. His dog is the cutest.
第八季马上就要接近尾声了。我真不敢相信。我们真的快接近尾声了，对吧？是的。谢谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯每周提供有用的信息。天哪，没有你我们真的做不出这个播客。我非常、非常、非常喜欢你对每一集制作幕后的所有见解。是的，史蒂夫，我也喜欢你给我们发照片的时候。你知道的，我的意思是，我喜欢你的黄毛猎犬。他的狗太可爱了。
He takes great pictures of him at Sunset. Steve is just a love bug. This is true. We've gotten a lot of dogs at Sunset Pictures. I love them. Steve, you're awesome. The rest of you are fantastic as well. Thanks for sending in your comments and your questions.
他在日落时分为它拍了很多很棒的照片。史蒂夫真是个可爱的宝藏。确实如此。我们在日落时分收到了很多狗狗的照片。我很喜欢它们。史蒂夫，你太棒了。你们其他人也同样棒。谢谢你们发来评论和提问。
Really and truly, you open up these episodes for us. You help us to see them in a new way, and we just appreciate you all so much. and your questions, really and truly you open up these episodes for us. You help us to see them in a new way, and we just appreciate you all so much. It's been really fun doing this rewatch with you. Alright, we'll see you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins.
真的非常感谢，你们为我们开启了这些剧集的新视角。你们帮助我们以一种崭新的方式看待它们，我们真的非常感激你们所有人和你们的问题，真的非常感谢你们为我们开启了这些剧集的新视角。你们帮助我们以一种崭新的方式看待它们，我们真的非常感激你们所有人。和你们一起重温这部剧真的非常有趣。好了，我们下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室淑女》。《办公室淑女》由Earwolf、珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our Associate Producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人是安斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。